So Leute, wisst ihr was wir machen?
Steht schon in Beatle, achso ich hab übrigens.
Passt mal auf, mal gucken ob das gescheit funktioniert ehrlich gesagt, mal schauen.
Ich hab übrigens, guck mal hier, die Kamera gefixt, weil ich mir nicht sicher bin ob das
sind 50 FPS, Sekunde, ich soll doch kurz überprüfen, sollten 50 FPS sein, ja sind 50 FPS, 50, 50 FPS
Mann, äh, hört ihr mich, ja, nimmt die Kamera, Moment, Sekunde, die Kamera von dieser komischen
App, nimmt was auf, das soll die überhaupt nicht, ich muss die mal kurz disablen, die
macht komische Sachen.
So guck mal, ich hab die Kamera gefixt, Mini-ITX-Kackel, Alter, das Board ist riesengroß, ja, schaut
mal, ich hab die Kamera gefixt, die ruckelt jetzt nicht mehr und macht jetzt mit 50 FPS
nicht mehr so auf Cac-Weight.
Es ist, es ist immer noch das, oh, jetzt hat's geruckelt, lull, ich hab's gesehen, ähm,
da sind wir noch das iPhone, ja, also da, da oben ist immer noch das iPhone, aber besser,
besser eingestellt.
Und das schöne ist, ich hab da jetzt so eine Software, da kann ich jetzt auch so Sachen
wie Sättigung einstellen oder Mirron oder Stabili-Leisen und Zeug, ich kann theoretisch
sogar rotaten, was jetzt denn wirklich was bringt, ja, ich kann zum Beispiel rotaten
und dann, ähm, scrollen, wobei das ziemlich ein Blödsinn ist, wir machen das wieder
ursprünglich, so wie es sein soll, wir könnten's auch so rum machen, aber das sieht, das sieht
ziemlich pepege aus, da ist es nämlich spiegelverkehrt, dann checkt ja keiner was, im Endeffekt,
so muss das sein.
Die Maske, die Maske ist nice, ne, Leute, ich muss jetzt mal ernsthaft, das ist wirklich
ernst gemeint, das letzte Mal war ja just for fun, mal angenommen, ich lass so was drucken,
irgendwie 500 Stück oder so, Einzelexemplare kosten natürlich ein bisschen was, wenn ich
mir die einzeln machen lasse, aber ich denke, wenn ich da 500 Stück bestelle oder so, dann
sieht das schon besser aus, nicht unbedingt vielleicht mit der, mit dem Motiv, ich würd'
sagen, man kann dann, wir machen, wir machen drei Motive zur Auswahl, ja, wir machen den
geschockten Keks, wir machen den, den, den cute Ayaya Keks und, und so was, übrigens,
ich zeig euch mal was, Zack, es gibt neue, es gibt Emote, Emote Previews, Moment, es
gibt neue, neue Emote Previews, wenn ich die jetzt, wenn ich die finde, wartet mal kurz,
ähm, ich muss es mal kurz raussuchen, so, download, wartet mal, wartet mal, ich muss
es mal kurz rüberkopieren, ich hab's noch nicht, ich hab's noch nicht hinkopiert, so,
Folder, kann man das so rüberkopieren, nice, also, es gibt neue, es gibt neue Bilder, Leute,
ich, entpacke das einfach mal auf dem Desktop, wir haben, also, wir haben neue Bilder, paar
mal, paar mal das gleiche Bild, weil ich nicht genau weiß, welche sich nehmen will, wir haben
neue Bilder, guck mal, wir haben, den, den ersten wollte ich nicht, wir haben cute, wir
haben cute Keks, für alle, für alle Weeps unter uns, das, das da sind Waro Keks, wir
haben, wir haben cute Keks, wir haben Giga Chat Keks, wir haben Fett, Fett Keks, ups,
Fett Keks, und wir haben Bettke, Puma müde, Puma schlafen, Keks haben wir, ich muss jetzt
sagen, das kannst du fast als Animation benutzen, gut, aber jetzt mal zurück zum eigentlichen
Thema, ich schalte mal wieder um, ja, also, ich hab jetzt ein Software, damit kann ich
das anpassen, hier zum Beispiel bei der, bei der, ach nee, wo war ich gerade, also mal angenommen,
mal angenommen, wir machen, wir suchen uns irgendwie drei, drei coole Motive raus, ja,
vielleicht den da, vielleicht einmal den, den, den klassischen mit Kopfhörer und noch
irgendwas, die Sache ist halt die, es haben jetzt ganz viele Leute gesagt, oh ja, die
Maske ist nice, mal angenommen, nur mal theoretisch, ja, mal angenommen, ich würde da 500 Stück
von drucken lassen, ich würde die ja nicht selbst ausliefern, ich würde das dann über
irgendeinen Merchandising Store machen, da gibt es ja tausende von, wie groß ist das
Interesse an echter Keksmaske, mit Aufpreis meinetwegen sogar signiert, ja, also, würdet
ihr eine Keksmaske haben wollen, es muss nicht die sein, es muss exakt dieses Motiv sein,
irgendeins von diesen Keksen, und wenn wir gerade dabei sind, vielleicht noch ein paar
andere Sachen, Teile schon da, ja, bis auf das Gehäuse, aber der, der Kontaktframe ist
da, wir können heute anfangen zu bauen, also wollt ihr, wollt ihr, wollt ihr eine Keksmaske,
weil dann kann ich mal 500 Stück oder so in Auftrag geben, aber wie gesagt, und dann ist
halt die nächste Frage, muss keine Maske sein, das ist stellvertretend, Leute, ersetzt Maske,
ersetzt Maske auch beispielsweise mal durch T-Shirt oder Tasse oder irgendwas, die Sache
ist halt die, ich hab halt keinerlei Erfahrung, was irgendwelche Merchandise-Geschichten angeht,
Unterhosen, ja, Socken, was auch immer, gibt's ja alles mögliche, ich hab keinerlei Erfahrung,
was Merchandising-Geschichten angeht, aber, wo ich mir am allerschwersten tue, ist, wie
viel Jahre, ja, so ein Body-Pillow für die, warum nicht, ja, ich hab halt keine Ahnung,
was ein angemessener Preis so ist, ja, mal angenommen, mal angenommen, man würde irgendwie
ein T-Shirt machen, ich hab keine Ahnung, kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen auf die
Größe an, ja, Tasse, Socken, was auch immer, ich hab halt keine Ahnung, ich mein guck mal,
wenn man so Einzelmasken stellt, das kostet über 10 Euro das Stück, das ist ja auch
Stoff hier und sonst was, wenn man da 500 Stück davon bestellt, ist es billiger, aber
ich glaub, kaum einer will so ein Ding für 5 Euro plus das Stück bestellen, plus Versand,
kommt ja noch dabei, einfach viel zu teuer, ja, und das muss man sich beim T-Shirt auch
irgendwie überlegen, dass das irgendwas, ja, ich weiß nicht, ich hab da echt keine Ahnung
von, das lass ich meinem Manager machen, der muss auch, der muss auch gucken bei sowas
immer, tja, ich weiß, ich auch, ich würde auch nicht mit dem Keks rumrennen, aber es
haben jetzt über die letzten Jahre immer wieder Leute geschrieben, ja, muss ja auch
nix öffentlich getragenes sein, ich hätte halt schon gerne was, was man im Zweifelsfall
auch anziehen kann, also jetzt nicht unbedingt den da oder so, sondern irgendwas mit irgendwas
bisschen, bisschen neutraleres, den Hacker-Man-Keks zum Beispiel, ja, Sticker für ein Laptop,
Leute, sind richtig gute Ideen dabei, ich schreib mir das mal auf, ja, ja, sowas, also
gute Idee, ja, kann man alles machen, ok, also prinzipiell gibt es ein paar, die das
interessiert, die Maske hier, ne, die bringt nix, die hat eine Einlage für ein FFP2-Ding,
aber wisst ihr, die Maske ist auch nicht gegen Corona gedacht, wisst ihr wofür die Maske
gedacht ist, die ist Anti-Leak gedacht, Moment, ich probier das mal kurz aus, Anti-Leak,
nee, ich kann das nicht ausprobieren, ich wollte mir grad die Maske aufziehen und dann
meinen Kopf hier drunter schieben, das Problem ist bloß, so gelenkig bin ich nicht rückwärts,
dass ich hier im 90 Grad Winkel meinen Kopf rückwärts reinschieben kann, die ist dafür
gedacht, dass wenn ich mich spiegele, dass ich mich nicht leake, Anti-Leak-Maske ist
das ja, also dass man nicht ausläuft, so, wir müssen mal kurz die Overwatch Weihnachtsmusik
ausmachen, hat das jetzt wieder umgeschaltet, sollte eigentlich wieder umschalten, ah jetzt
hat es umgeschaltet, ja OBS-Shortcuts muss ich mir noch mal ein bisschen merken, okay,
ja muss ich ja mal angucken, Overwatch-Musik aus, okay, welchen Browser, Chrome, ja, okay,
Chrome, also das ist Chromium, das ist quasi Chrome, nur mit ein paar Chrome-Dingern entfernt,
okay Leute, also folgendermaßen sieht es aus mit dem Bauen heute, gucken ob das umschalten
tut, ey nice, das funktioniert, ich bin begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert, ist das, Chet, ist
das hier alles hell genug, ich hoffe, weil das muss hell genug sein, weil ich habe hier
oben das Ring-Light drum herum, ja, und so, ne, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu,
Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu, Pogu,
Die Kabel am Rand, ja das kann ich anders machen, hier ist eine Steckdose, oh es hat
geruckelt, ich hab's gesehen, hier ist eine Steckdose und da hinten ist halt der Switch,
normalerweise steht ja, also wer die anderen Basteldinger kennt, der weiß ja, normalerweise
steht hier ein Switch und da liegt dann vielleicht ein Raspberry Pi rum oder so und hier ist
dann die Steckdosenleiste, aber ich musste das halt alles wegmachen, dass es ansatzweise
hier draufpasst.
Also, nachdem wir uns gestern, übrigens Leute, immer noch Prime Subs, nachdem wir uns gestern
ja schon die ganzen Teile angeguckt haben, heute ist endlich auch der Kontaktframe angekommen,
dass man die CPU festmachen kann, bzw. hier, original, original, der Bauer Kontaktframe,
warum den und nicht den Thermaltake, ganz einfach, weil der nicht lieferbar war und
jetzt kann ich die CPU damit festmachen, warum braucht man sowas?
Eigentlich braucht man sowas gar nicht, das ist, die letzten paar Intel CPU Generationen
haben die blöde Angewohnheit, dass die sich unter Druck vom Lüfter ein bisschen biegen
und deswegen nicht so korrekt planen, aufliegen und damit kann man ein paar Temperaturen,
paar Punkte, Temperaturpunkte, also paar Grad, Temperaturpunkte, alter, paar Grad senken,
je nach CPU, muss nicht unbedingt klappen, aber muss ich warten bis er da ist.
So, kompletten Rechner, also sprich komplett ins Gehäuse einbauen können wir heute noch
nicht, weil, ganz einfach, das Gehäuse ist noch nicht da, so siehts aus und wenn das
Gehäuse noch nicht da ist, kann ich kompletten Rechner nicht zusammenbauen, das heißt was
wir heute machen ist, wir bereiten heute mal das Mainboard vor, mit diesem Kontaktframe
drauf, machen den Sockel ab, müssen uns da bestimmt auch das eine oder andere Video
von angucken, dass ich weiß wie das funktioniert, ich hab schon mal grob drüber geguckt, mal
schauen ob ichs hinkrieg, Testaufbau, genau, wir machen die Wasserkühlung dran, wir machen
logischerweise das Netzteil dran, die SSD aufs Mainboard, vielleicht installieren wir auch
Windows schon, da muss ich aber mal gucken, da muss ich meine Capture Card irgendwie im
Schrank erst noch suchen, dann installieren wir, vielleicht, also da bin ich mir noch
nicht ganz sicher, je nachdem wie lange der andere Kram dauert, dann installieren wir
Windows drauf, machen vielleicht mal nen Benchmark und Kram drauf logischerweise, ja und gucken
wie das mit Temperaturen und sowas ist und wie die RGB Beleuchtung ist, dein Merch mit
Blazingly Fast, das ist aber Rust Niem, das ist ja gar nicht meins, ok, also, ich hole
mal kurz, also wir machen mal kurz den da weg, den legen wir da hinten hin, dass man
den Staub nicht so sieht, da kommt der Keks, der kann bisschen den Staub kaschieren, so,
den Kontaktframe und das Zeug, das legen wir hier oben hin, Schraubchamp kommt auch hier
oben hin, gut, dann hole ich mal das Mainboard und wir gucken uns das ganze an, wie das funktioniert,
ich hab das nämlich noch nie gemacht, hat jemand von euch schon mal so nen Kontaktframe
installiert oder hat vielleicht schon mal jemand von euch dann in Kombination noch ne,
in Arctic Freezer Wasserkühler installiert, mit der Maske, ne die hab ich nur daheim an,
also fangen wir mal an, Mainboard, muss das mal kurz rausholen hier, also als erstes hätten
wir die CPU, die in so nem komischen Oblade drin ist, weil Intel sich gedacht hat, ja
für 750 Euro kann man auch mal ne gescheite Verpackung machen, dann Grafikkarten, Stromkabel,
RGB-Kabel, jetzt, erstmal nicht, brauch ich jetzt erstmal nicht direkt, Netzteil werde
ich auf jeden Fall brauchen, also gucken, das lege ich dann da hinten hin, das wird man
nicht direkt sehen, das mach ich mal hier wieder runter, erstmal müssen wir das Mainboard
vorbereiten, da brauchen wir das nicht, das legen wir auch mal hier hinten hin, so CPU
brauchen wir, dann RAM und SSD, RAM und SSD brauchen wir, Leute was da liegt sind 500
Euro RAM, krasser Preis oder, ganz schön teuer, 500 Euro für so fucking 2 Sticks RAM, nein
Gehäuse ist nicht da, 2x32, 2x32, 6400 DDR5, um genau zu sein, hier erkennt man's, guckt,
6400, CL, 32, 39, 32, das ist ordentlich was, brauchen tut man's nicht, genauso wie den
kompletten Rechner, wie gesagt aktuell, nur noch mal zum Vergleich Leute, aktuell hab
ich einen 8700K, also das hier ist ein 13900K, aktuell hab ich einen 8700K, bisschen übertaktet,
aber mittlerweile nicht mehr, nicht mehr übertaktet und 230G RAM, 1080Ti, also das ist jetzt gar
kein schlechter Rechner, das ist immer noch besser als der Steam Durchschnitt, weit besser
als der Steam Durchschnitt, ja, das ist Crypt of the Necrodancer, korrekt, Prog Soundtrack,
hör ich mega gern, find ich auch super wenn man was programmieren will oder so im Hintergrund,
obwohl ich das, also ich kenn das Spiel, das Spiel ist auch nice, hab ich aber nie super
ausführlich gespielt, aber der Soundtrack ist nice, ja, so, also, wie gesagt aktuell
8700K, 1080Ti, 230G RAM, SSD natürlich und alles mögliche, aber das ist immer noch deutlich
besser als das meiste was die Leute auf Steam haben, ich hab letztens gelesen, die Leute
haben auf Steam glaub ich eine GeForce 1600 oder so im Durchschnitt, also die, nein nicht
im Durchschnitt, die verbreitetste Grafikkarte, die verbreitet, so muss man sagen, die verbreitetste
Grafikkarte auf Steam ist aktuell 1060, nicht 1060, oder 1650 mittlerweile kann auch sein,
ja es ist halt wirklich ramsch, ja, vergleich zu dem anderen, weltweit alle Accounts, ja
gut, ich hab ja gesagt im Durchschnitt, ja, also das verglichen mit dem ist natürlich
mein Rechner, den ich jetzt hab, immer noch die Wucht, aber der ist 5 Jahre alt, es wird
einfach mal wieder Zeit was Neues zu bauen, gut, so, ähm, CPU mach ich mal kurz hier
neben hin, RAM, RAM und SSD werden wir gleich verbauen, Mainboard, komm raus hier, wo bist
du? Moment, das ist die Festplatte, Sack, SATA Kabel, Anti-Static Pad, ok, so, Mainboard,
ich überleg grad, wie ich das am besten hier platziere, dass ihr was seht, ich denke mal
so, ja, ich denke so dürfte am besten sein, da erkennt man ein bisschen was, die SSD ist
klein, ja, und dazu kommt das kleine Furzding, ist 2TB groß, ja, guckt euch das mal an,
ATX Stecker und hier hinten nochmal 2x8 Stromstecker, ich vermute mal die müssen einfach alle dran
und dann kriegt die Grafikkarte, passt mal auf, am Ende kriegt die Grafikkarte nochmal
32 Stecker, also, das hier ist übrigens, wer das noch nicht gesehen hat, das ist dieser
sagenumwobene Stromstecker, der ab und zu mal abfackelt, wenn ich das iPhone mal feststellen
würde, das ist der, der ab und zu mal abfackelt, naja, das machen wir aber dann, und bevor
wir die SSD und das RAM und sowas drauf machen, widmen wir uns mal dem Kontaktframe und dem
Mounting Plate oder wie man das nennt, für die Wasserkühlung, also wenn ich das Video
vom Bauer richtig geguckt habe, dann muss man das hier abmachen, Remove, ach ne, muss
man erstmal aufmachen, so, also hier kommt die CPU rein, ok nice, wie remove ich das,
ach so, einfach abklipsen, ok easy, ich bin zu blöd das abzukriegen, keck, ach ne, einfach
so, ok easy, so, hier muss man jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen, also diese Pins, nicht die Pins
verbiegen, genau, also hier muss man aufpassen, die Pins sind wirklich empfindlich mittlerweile,
ja, deswegen, ich hab das Video vom Bauer geguckt und man soll zuerst die CPU einsetzen
hier und dann soll man den anderen Krempel erst abmachen, aber wir gucken uns das mal,
wir gucken uns das mal zusammen, muss man sich erden, ja ich hab um mein Bein ein Anti-Static-Armband,
passt schon, wie glaubt ihr mir das nicht oder was, soll ich euch meinen Fuß zeigen,
soll ich euch meinen Fuß zeigen, guck seht ihr nicht, da ist, ne, mehr krieg ich nicht,
mehr krieg ich nicht ins Bild, Hyper Gachi, ja ja, Leute ihr Heizung, exellent, gut, also,
wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, als erstes, CPU einsetzen, also, da ist er, der Gute,
Intel, 13.900, warum ist es die CPU geworden, soll ich vielleicht noch mal kurz was dazu
erzählen, ganz einfach, weil ich sie haben wollte, nicht weil es sinnvoll ist, also für
meine Ansprüche, beziehungsweise das was ich machen will, hätte 13.700 auch ohne Probleme
getan, weil ich hab viele VMs laufen, ich mach Video Rendering und ich mach Streams und
Games, Sache ist halt die, ja theoretisch, hat dann 13.900 fürs ab und zu mal Video Render
natürlich einen Vorteil, also wenn einer noch einen Vorteil hat von, dann ich, aber ich
mach halt weder oft 3D Renders noch wirklich langes Rendering, eigentlich braucht man es
nicht, so, da ist er, jetzt machen wir den mal auf, guck da, da ist so ein Ding, da ist
er, Poggers, so, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie man den Kram einsetzt, früher hatten
die Dinger so ne Ecke, ich glaub die haben immer noch so ne Ecke, ja guck da haben sie
ne Ecke, und die Ecke ist, wo muss die Ecke hin, also ich geh davon aus, dass es nur in
eine Richtung reinpasst ehrlich gesagt, pass auf die Pins auf XD, ja, also ich würde,
ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, dass es so rum reinkommt, ne
falsch rum, Kekkel oder, ja so, so rum, so rum, so rum kommt es rein, so ist richtig,
unten links sieht man ich seh da nix, Leute wenn ihr gebannt werden wollt, es gibt eine
Sache die mich unglaublich triggert, es ist offensichtlich, dass ich es nicht gesehen
habe wo das hinkommt, so, dieses mann bist du dumm backseating sieht man doch, also wenn
es eine Sache gibt, das wisst ihr ja, wenn es eine Sache die mich unglaublich triggert
dann ist es sowas, so, also ich hab's nicht gesehen, woran sieht man das, also ich seh
hier unten diese Markierung ja, aber die ist ja auf der CPU und woran würde man jetzt
erkennen, dass das da rein muss, ah, da ist ein Pfeil, den seh ich von hier aus nicht,
ihr seht den Pfeil, ich seh den nicht, ja wenn ich in meiner Vorschau gucke seh ich
den auch, ich seh den nicht aus meiner, weil ich steh ja hier, guck mal, ich steh hier
aus meiner Sicht dieses Ding da vor, ich seh das nicht, siehste, schon gar nicht so offensichtlich
wenn man es nicht sieht, hier ist er, guck da, da ist eben so ein komischer Pfeil, so
jetzt haben wir die CPU reingelegt und ich vermute mal, jetzt muss ich hier neben einfach
abschrauben aber wir gucken uns nochmal schnell das Video vom Bauer an wie das funktioniert,
so schauen wir uns mal an, achso ihr seht gar nichts, kann das sein, ihr seht gar nichts,
jetzt seht ihr was, yep, hier der Bauer, ich sag mal neuerdings sind irgendwie in dem Browser
hier meine Bookmarks kaputt oder diese, diese Chapters sind irgendwie kaputt, willst du
für die NASA arbeiten?
Ich glaub die NASA hat deutlich schlechtere PCs, so hier baut das irgendwie ein Montage
des Kontakt Frames, um den neuen Rahmen zu montieren, müssen wir natürlich logischerweise
erstmal den alten abmachen, dazu machen wir das hier auf, ich empfehle euch, jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen flüssig Stickstoff drauf machen, ja Hammer, Hammer, CPU ist im Sockel, alles
klar, ach du Scheiße man, ach du Scheiße man, oh, ein Edding, ach du Scheiße man, ach
du Scheiße man, cinematic 270p, марkei als
Tekken, oder ein weißen Edding, ich hab was, ich hab was, ich hab irgendwo
was, Sekunde, Moment, Moment, Moment, Esk, sekunde, ich muss mal kurz gucken, Ich hab
Aber von very templracten, sehr spätten Lieder in der Hand, bin ich eigentlich auch具te Lieder
das da
das muss doch eigentlich auch gehen, oder?
Milwaukee
ähm
so
Marker
noch mal einen blauen
noch mal gucken ob das
funktioniert
keine Ahnung
ist ein blauer Strich drauf, okay das funktioniert
alles klar, haben wir
exellent
noch mal gesaved, ich hab schon gedacht
es scheitert
am adding
next
saved
dann markiert die eine stelle an der schraube
wie bei mir jetzt auf der rechten seite gesehen
ihr macht einfach einen strich an alle von diesen
schraubenköpfe, okay das kann ich
moment moment moment
das kann ich jetzt schon machen
ich mach einen strich an alle schraubenköpfe
okay
strich an alle schraubenköpfe leute
also
so
ist da jetzt was
ist da jetzt was blaues drauf
ja ja okay okay okay nice nice nice
okay nice
markiert
okay weiter
den contact frame
hier rein legen
der passt auch nur in eine richtung
zwischen hier und hier sind unterschiedlich
wo hat er denn den anderen
abgemacht dahinter, hier ist auch alles drauf
empfehle euch aber die cpu fliegt
dann ruiniert ihr nicht gleich die pins
im nächsten schritt würde ich empfehlen ihr nehmt einen
wasserfesten stift irgendwas das man gut auf einem dunklen
untergrund sehen kann
okay der hat es einfach abgeschraubt
der passt auch nur in eine richtung weil
die maße zwischen hier und hier sind unterschiedlich
passt auch nur genau so drauf
das ist auch wirklich wirklich wichtig
und auch der grund warum wir diese schlüsse hier mit liefern
das heißt ihr benutzt den
und montiert die schrauben damit ja
und ihr benutzt den auch nur zwischen diesen
zwei fingern wie ihr es hier sehen könnt das heißt
ihr schraubt die schrauben
im besten fall natürlich diagonal fest
so dass es
zwischen den fingern
nicht mehr weiter fest das kriege ich hin
zu ziehen ist also wenn ihr mit den fingern
das traue ich mir noch zu nicht mehr wirklich anziehen könnt
dann passt das erstmal
und jetzt kommt nämlich die skala zum
einsatz weil wir haben ja angegeben
0,03 bis 0,06 newtonmeter
okay
ich hab keinen drehmoment
schraubendreher oder schlüssel
für diese sache aber drehmoment und
keiner von uns hat drehmomentschlüssel
in dieser größenordnung normalerweise zuhause
deswegen ist es sehr sehr schwer
das abzubilden aber wir haben versucht es
einigermaßen einfach sag ich mal
nachvollziehbar zu machen deswegen haben wir
jetzt diese skala und die markierungen an
der schraube jetzt könnt ihr euch einfach merken
wo die position die schraube ist setzt das ding
an und jetzt um
eine viertel umdrehung also 90 grad
anziehen deswegen wurde
das markiert verstehe ich
hätte ohne probleme auch markieren können
nachdem ich die schrauben abgedreht habe
logischerweise bei allen also
ansetzen
viertel umdrehung
und dieser anpressdruck ist dann völlig
ausreichend weil je nachdem wie die toleranz von
6 hat time
dann machen wir das mal
und kurz musik bis ich wieder anmachen
richtig
extremely high IQ hier
ok also
deswegen haben wir auch die cpu drauf gemacht
vermute ich mal
dass wir nicht aus versehen hier dieses ding da drauf
schmeißen und dann was kaputt machen also ok
auf gehts
muss man kurz checken wie fest die
dinger sind ob es nicht vielleicht besser ist
das blöde ist chat ich muss
mal ein bisschen die sache bewegen
erstens liegt es schäb
jetzt liegt es nicht schäb und
so ich sehe
nix wenn es so weit dahinten ist ich hoffe ihr seht
noch was
so
ok das ist easy
die sind nicht fest
wobei wisst ihr was wisst ihr was
oh leute
zum los schrauben mache ich mal was anderes
pass mal auf
pass mal auf kann ich hier meinen
aha aha
der müsste passen denke ich mal
exellent
hopp
gleich viel angenehmer
angenehmer und
magnetisch
ok
und das ist so ein
ratschenschlüssel der kann man gar nicht
in die falsche richtung mit schrauben
cpu gelöscht ja genau
Siehste, deswegen habe ich dieses Ding, da kann man die schön da oben hin legen.
Das benutze ich nur zum abmachen, zu mehr nicht.
So, schrauben, ok, gut, jetzt ist es ab, das Neue, also das unten, die Platte bleibt
ja 1 zu 1 zu liegen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Sollen wir noch die Schrauben raus machen hier.
So, mal gucken, dass wir überall schöne, ja da ist ein blauer, seht ihr, da ist ein
blauer Strich drauf, irgendwo solltet ihr das jetzt eigentlich sehen, blauer Strich, guckt
da, blauer Strich, ja, da ist ein blauer Strich drauf, exellent, da ist ein blauer Strich
drauf, ok, da ist ein blauer Strich drauf und da ist auch ein blauer Strich drauf, ok,
wir haben alles richtig vorbereitet.
So, dieses Ding machen wir mal weg und jetzt setzen wir den Bauer hier drauf, wahrscheinlich
dann so rum, er sagt, es passt nur in eine Richtung drauf, das werde ich mal kurz überprüfen,
er hat recht, es passt nur in eine Richtung drauf, sehr gut gemacht, sehr gut durchdacht,
Pogu, einmal Pogu in den Chat für den Bauer, Idioten sicher, ja Moment, mal abwarten,
mal abwarten, so und jetzt hoffe ich, dass ich nicht zu viel Kraft zwischen Daumen und
Zeigefinger habe, alles reingerutscht hier, so und jetzt hat er gesagt, wir sollen nur
so drehen, nur so hier, guckt Leute, nur so, jetzt kann ich das auch mal gleich ein bisschen
bewegen, ok nur so, was ist wenn man zu viel Kraft in den Fingern hat, was ist wenn man
zu stark ist Chat?
Dann explodiert die CPU, war schlecht, sitze von wegen Idioten sicher, Kegwaid, ah jetzt
doch, äh irgendwie ist das komisch, warte mal, ich mach das mal kurz nochmal locker,
also richtig drin ist das ja, ok der hier ist schon angezogen, hä irgendwie greift
das gar nicht, warum nicht, das wartet mal, habe ich, ist das vielleicht unten drunter
verrutscht, ist eigentlich genau richtig so, ne jetzt gehts ok, keine Ahnung, jetzt gehts,
war vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen, gut, ja jetzt funktionierts, keine Ahnung was das
war, so jetzt machen wir die Schrauben erstmal nur locker fest, ne Moment die ist immer noch
nicht richtig fest, ok jetzt alles klar, ok also nur so weit fest drehen wie man das hinbekommt
damit, ok nice, nur so weit fest drehen wie man das damit hinbekommt ok, ok so also leute
ich habs fest, ich habs fest soweit, so und jetzt hat er gesagt ne viertel drehung, also
ne viertel drehung von der blauen markierung her, also die blaue markierung ist da unten,
also muss ich die kurz, wartet mal, machen wir das mal so hin, dass ihr das seht, so
hier ist die blaue markierung, keine ahnung ob ihr die blaue markierung erkennt, wahrscheinlich
nicht, aber machen jetzt einfach mal blaue markierung bis dahin, so hier ist die blaue
markierung, ich seh die gar nicht, da oben, da oben, das heißt die blaue markierung machen
wir da, ein viertel, so korrekt, so das haben wir angezogen, hier ist die blaue markierung,
ok die blau, blau war ne blöde idee, die ist oben, die ist oben rechts, also viertel umdrehung,
gut haben wir noch unten links, da ist die blaue markierung, da, viertel umdrehung, ok
gut, glaub ich hab ein Stückchen zu weit, ja ok, so das wars, ja du hast eigentlich vollkommen
recht, viertel umdrehung ist viertel umdrehung, ja das mit der markierung hätte man sich eigentlich
fast sparen können, ok also jetzt haben wir den kram drauf, sehr gut, das kann man dann
wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden hab noch ein bisschen, ja da wackelt, da wackelt nix, bisschen
nachjustieren falls es irgendwie, und dann kann man ein bisschen rumprobieren mit temperaturen
und allem, so nice, ich mach das mal anders, wir machen das hier mal kurz weg, ich schieb
mal das ganze teil hier ein bisschen hoch, so und dann setz ich das damit ihr es besser
seht beziehungsweise dass es ein bisschen flacher auf liegt, das ist nämlich ein bisschen,
jetzt liegt es nämlich flach auf, so hin, gut also was kommt als nächstes, chat was
machen wir als nächstes, die ssd wahrscheinlich oder ram, ssd, wir machen erstmal ssd, also
ssd, ssd, ja gut, da haben wir unten einmal wärmelight pad, ok erstmal die ssd kurz hier
holen, da, ssd, so rum musst du dann rein, lassen wir mal das wärmelight pad ab, oh jetzt
hab ich das komplette wärmelight pad abgezogen, keckel, ok das ist ein bisschen schlecht,
ok, rein damit, rein stecken, ich seh es nicht, ok klips, drinne ist es, drinne ist es, alles
klar, jetzt müssen wir hier oben wahrscheinlich das noch abziehen, ok, warum ist da ein loch
drin, ach das ist wo die schraube war, so, ok, und das soll jetzt gut halten, ja, ok,
ssd kann man es nicht mehr drehen, ok, wenn gigabyte sagt, dass es so hält, zielt man
den ssd ab, also man kann das machen, aber wahrscheinlich wenn du die einschicken musst
gibt es dann probleme, traube vergessen, es gibt keine schraube, es gibt keine schraube,
das ist so ein klipssystem, da klips man das rein, ich vermute mal das ist ok so, wir gucken
uns nachher die ssd temperaturen an, so das haben wir, das hier bleibt zu, da kann man
bis zu 3 weitere ssds drunter machen, das brauchen wir aber nicht, da gucken wir uns
mal ram an, so ram, also ram bänke, ddr a1, a2, guckt hier, oh was haben wir denn hier,
was packen wir da dran, da steht es, ddr, seht ihr das, ddr a1, a2, b1, b2, was ich jetzt
nicht weiß ist, was muss man für dual channel machen, macht man dann a1 und b1 oder a1 und
a2, da steht first, ach da steht first tatsächlich, aha, ok, ok also macht man zuerst b2 und a2,
also macht man zuerst quasi den da und den da, da hatte ich es doch richtig, den da und
den da, ok, aha, aha, aha, ja gut, ist es richtig, ja, Achtung, Clips, Clips, next,
jetzt erstmal ne 4te Kerbe unten, ne 2te Kerbe unten rein machen, ist noch nicht richtig
drinnen, hast recht, das, Sissy ihr seht das besser dahinten, ich kann da nicht hingucken
gescheit, jetzt, ok, Ram drinnen, so schmeißen wir das mal weg, Ram ist drinnen, was brauchen
wir denn als nächstes, Strom oder, also beziehungsweise die Wasserkühlung eigentlich, wir haben noch
ne viertel Umdrehung, hab ich schon irgendwas vergessen, ne oder, Wasserkühlung, muss zum
Schluss, das ist der Schluss, ach so, ne, ne das ist der Schluss, Gehäuse hab ich ja
noch nicht, das ist halt einfach nur mal testen, du hast jetzt einen ganzen Monat Urlaub, POG,
ich auch, ich hab aber schon seit 20. November oder so, Urlaub bis 3. Januar oder wann das
ist, POGU, POG LIKE THIS, alles klar, gut, Leute ich hol mal die Wasserkühlung, jetzt
kommt das fette Teil, da muss der Keks hier mal kurz, ah der Keks kann drunter liegen
bleiben, da müssen wir aber das Mainboard wahrscheinlich mal ein Stückchen bewegen,
hier vorne hin, sodass es grad aufliegt, weil wir müssen jetzt ja gleich, hier CPU-Kühler
und so, ach ne Moment, wir müssen das, die Wasserkühlung hätten wir vor RAM und sowas
machen sollen, weil wir müssen das jetzt umdrehen und mounten und sowas, ok ich hol
mal das Mounting Kit, ich mach mal das RAM wieder raus, RAM war bescheuert drauf zu machen,
RAM ist jetzt eher im Weg, na, RAM, geh auf, Leute 500 MB RAM in so zwei kleinen Dinger,
Monka Kek, Monka Kek, Hallo, der David fragt, uuuh, gibt's hier Leute die wie ich, DevOps
sind und Kubernetes administrieren, David kommst du aus Spanien, ich sag dir auch warum
ich das frage, nein ok dann nicht, ich kenne nämlich zwei Davids aus Spanien, hätte ja
sein können, man weiß ja nie, ob's jetzt bin ich gegen das Kabel gedonnert mit dem
Knie gerade, äh gegen meine Verlängerung, aber ich muss mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz,
ich muss mal kurz mein, mein Headset entwirren, ich bin wieder da, was, was die Gründe waren
für den 13900K, ja weil mein aktueller CPU, weil mein aktueller CPU zu langsam ist, der
RAM wieder raus, weil jetzt die Wasserkühlung dran kommt und dazu muss man das Board wahrscheinlich
rumdrehen, Achtung, Wasserkühlung on, on the way, warte mal, die Grafikkarte liegt auf
dem Stecker drauf, Grafikkarte, geh weg, fettes Teil man, pepo fett, Headshaming bei Grafikkarte,
Body Positivity Grafikkarte, so hier Wasserkühlung, also Leute, ich hab ja, ich bin ja nicht ganz,
ganz bescheuert, ich mein ich bin bescheuert, aber ich bin nicht ganz bescheuert, deswegen
habe ich mir natürlich im Vorfeld ein bisschen was angeguckt zum Thema Wasserkühlung und
die Sache ist die, wenn man eine Wasserkühlung im Gehäuse einbaut, ist das überhaupt kein
Problem, bei der M2 fehlt nicht die Schraube, hier ist die Schraube drin und die M2 ist
in so einem Clips, das ist so ein Clips-System, da muss man nix mehr schrauben, das Clips
man da rein, ich würd's dir zeigen, wenn ich jetzt nicht schon das Klebepad drauf gemacht
hätte, also ich hab mich ein bisschen schlau gemacht, was Wasserkühlung angeht, also wenn
man die oben im Gehäuse montiert, ist das gar kein Problem, weil dann ist die Pumpe,
das hier ist die Pumpe, by the way, das ist die Pumpe hier, Pumpe, Pumpchamp, der Pumpchamp,
das ist die Pumpe unterhalb von dem Ding und die Luft steigt nach oben, wenn man das nicht
kann, dann soll man gucken, dass hier an der Seite, das unten ist und das hier oben, dass
die Luft quasi hier auf diese Seite hoch steigt, das heißt, wenn ich richtig aufgepasst hab,
müsste ich die Wasserkühlung quasi so platzieren hier, damit wir die jetzt hier auf dem Tisch
betreiben können. So. Ist das korrekt, Chet? Backseated mich mal. Du kannst die Dinge auch
oben haben, ne, wenn du das oben hast, also wenn du das obendrehst, dann hast du das Problem,
dass die Luft hier nach oben steigt und die Pumpe nicht richtig ansauen kann. Es gibt
eine M2 Schraube, ja, da nicht, das ist ein Clipsystem, da brauchst du keine Schraube
mehr. Da, da, Clips, du, warte mal, ich zeig's dir, ich zeig's dir. Das scheint den Chet
unglaublich zu beschäftigen, dass ich wahrscheinlich die SSD falsch eingebaut hab. Also, ich zeig's
euch, guck dir mal. Guck dir mal her, Jungs. Und Mädels. Sind überhaupt Mädels da? Ich
bezweifle es, aber man weiß ja nie. Du kannst ja auch Mädels für Hardware interessieren,
warum nicht? Heutzutage ist das ja alles möglich. So, guckt mal. Hier. Das hat Schnellverschlüsse,
seht ihr das? Hier. Zup. Zup. Du hast keine Schraube mehr, du machst den Schnellverschluss
hier auf und so, und wenn du es draufsitzt, clips das rein und wenn du es aufmachen willst,
machst du so. Also, Baladi, ich glaube, das letzte, was jemand schreiben würde, wäre
das, um auf sich aufmerksam zu machen. Hallo, Buba, Buba, hallo. Cringe. So, machen wir
das wieder zu. Gut. Übrigens, was ich an der Stelle vielleicht
auch nochmal erwähnen sollte, es hat nichts mit CPUs und Wasserkühlung zu tun, aber solltet
ihr euren Twitch-Account mit Amazon Prime verknüpft haben, dann kriegt ihr einen kostenlosen
Prime-Sub im Monat und da kann ich euch nur empfehlen, das einem Streamer eurer Wahl zu
geben, weil ansonsten überweist ihr das direkt an Besos. Ich will es gar nicht haben, wenn
ich es kriege, freue ich mich natürlich drüber, aber lasst es nicht verfallen. David, danke
schön für den Sub. Lasst es nicht verfallen. Gibt es, also, ich meine, wie gesagt, ich
will jetzt nicht sagen, gibt es nicht mir, gibt es gerne mir, ich freue mich, aber gibt
es irgendjemand, ja. Move like Jagger am Start. Dankeschön, dankeschön, Leute. Ach ja,
und David, ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Kubernetes-Administrator. Ich bin Senior DevOps-Ingenieur.
Oder Senior Linux-Ingenieur. Oder demnächst Senior System-Administrator wieder. Was auch
immer, kannst du mich nennen, wie du willst. Aber Kubernetes hab ich ein bisschen planen,
so ist das nicht, aber ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Kubernetes-Administrator. Also ich kann ein
Deployment machen und sowas, ja. Ich kann nicht sagen, was ein Pod ist. Aber ansonsten,
Linux kenne ich mich auch aus. Linux habe ich 15 Jahre Erfahrung mittlerweile. Senior
C++-Ingenieur, MonkaS. Didi, dankeschön für den Sub. Was noch? Tonaios, POG-Subscriptions.
Danke, danke, Leute. PhysX, auf Wieder-abend-Start, 10 Monate. Huge. Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
Leute. Nice, nice, nice, nice. Du hast einen LPG 2 gemacht, ich hab nie einen LPG gemacht.
Ich hab außer mal CCNA in meiner Ausbildung nie was gemacht. Ich drück mich immer um
alle möglichen Zertifizierungen und sowas. Radiosignale, Sariks. Ach nee, Wolle hat geschenkt.
Dankeschön für die zwei gegifteten Subs. Hast du gezielt gegiftet? Oder haben alle
anderen erfolgreich gedodged? Aber die zwei, die du ausgesucht hast, haben sie auf jeden
Fall verdient, die sind oft da. Die können es gebrauchen. Dann hat der Randomizer gut
entschieden heute. Easy-Dodge. Easy. Gut, also, machen wir mal weiter. Wasserkühlung.
CPU. Jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen. Ah, Moment, ich muss das Montage-Kit holen.
Das, das Montage. Quickscope Montage-Kit. Das. Irgendwelche Bits. Eine Million Bits,
ich kann's... Wilder Igel, glaub ich. Ich hab's grad nur auf meiner Vorschau nicht richtig
gesehen. Dankeschön, Wilder Igel. 100 Millionen. Pogu. Danke, danke. Hier, Liquid Freezer 2.
Upgrade-Kit. Für LGA 1700. Das ist das Richtige. Okay, Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt mal kurz
ein Video an, wie man das richtig montiert, weil ich hab das noch nie gemacht. Bevor
ich da jetzt irgendwas verkacke, schauen wir mal kurz. Freezer. Arctic Freezer. Installation.
Montage oder so. How to install Liquid Freezer. Installation auf AM4. Nein, Installation auf
7. Jawoll. Jawoll. Sehr schön. Hat er auch die Wärmeleitpaste auf dem Sockel? Ich hab
noch keine Wärmeleitpaste drauf. Hey, Guys. Welcome to Cleebs Tech. Today we're going
to show you how to install Liquid Freezer 2 on an LGA 1700 motherboard. On your screen
you're going to see what we have in our Liquid Freezer 2 kit. This is an older revision,
and on the bottom right corner you see the LGA 1700 mounting kit we are going to be using.
And the top left corner in the blue is the radiator mounting stuff that we are not going
to be going over.
Ja gut, den Radiator mounte ich ja heute auch nicht. Der bleibt einfach am Rand stehen.
Guck, mein Radiator steht ja da. Ich weiß nicht, sieht man denn überhaupt auf der Kamera
ein bisschen? Ja, da. Da sieht man Teile vom... Alter. Mount a radiator elsewhere on YouTube,
but today we're just going to be showing you how to mount the pump walk to your motherboard
basically. So we're going to be using everything you see on the bottom right. Okay, okay, das
Kit. Das ist das, was ich schon rausgesucht habe. Okay, easy. Weiter, hopp, mach hinne.
If you buy a Liquid Freezer 2 package that includes the LGA 1700 mounting kit, this is
what you'll be looking at. Pretty much the only things we're not going to be using are
these standoffs. You see X-Stat on the bottom. Ja. The standoffs we are going to use are 13
mm long and the middle section. Wozu braucht man das? Damit man seine Wasserkühlung montieren
kann. These are the parts we're going to be using. Das die hält. We're going to use this
as a reference as to what we're pulling out. Please note that the metal, there are metal
washers and rubber o-rings and we are not going to use the metal washers at all in this
small video. Metal washers? Von was spricht ihr? Was sind metal washers? Unterlegscheibe.
Ach. Nee, du siehst, da ist keine Wärmeleitpaste drauf. Okay, das kriege ich hin. Das machen
wir jetzt, Leute. Wir machen das einfach mit dem zusammen. Easy. Also, ich schalte mal um.
Ja, danke für die ganzen Subs, Leute. Ich hoffe, ich habe keinen übersehen. Aber müsste
eigentlich alle haben. So, wir machen das jetzt einfach mit dem zusammen. Okay, also hier
ist das Mounting Kit. Mounting Kit. Wird ein bisschen eng hier auf dem Tisch. So, also
wir brauchen auf jeden Fall die... Oh, jetzt ist hier, wisst ihr, jetzt ist schon fast wieder
hier was kaputt gegangen. So, wir haben das Zeug. Wir machen das mal hier oben rein. Hier,
die brauchen wir jetzt. Die brauchen wir jetzt. Das sind jetzt die Teile, die Radar gerade
rausgeholt hat. Kommt nicht dran, oder? So, das sind die Teile, die Radar gerade rausgeholt
hat. Und das andere, das kippen wir mal hier oben hin. Schauen wir nämlich gleich nach.
Okay, gut. Wisst ihr, deswegen mag ich diese Unterlage. Da hat man so Ablagefächer. Das
ist ganz praktisch. Okay. Ich glaube, das war es, oder? Seht ihr noch irgendwas? Ich
sehe nichts mehr. War es das? Nein, ich glaube, das war es. Wir sehen was runtergefallen,
oder? Das war es, glaube ich. Die schwarzen Schrauben fehlen bestimmt. Moment, gibt es
da vielleicht noch ein anderes Pack? Ah, hier ist ein AMD Pack. Ach ja, Moment, da sind
noch mehr Sachen drinne. Okay, okay. Das ist nur das Upgrade Kit für, alles klar.
Haben wir nämlich noch mehr. Wir haben Wärmeleitpaste. Wir haben noch mehr solcher komischen Abstandshalter
oder was das ist. Wir haben Schrauben, die hat er gesagt, die brauchen wir jetzt aber
nicht. Und irgendwelche anderen Mounting-Dinger. Und hier haben wir noch mal welche. Okay.
Na gut. Die Backplate liegt da. So, ich denke mal, also das hier werden wir nicht brauchen.
Ich denke, wir brauchen hier noch die Schrauben raus. Ja. Okay, das ist natürlich auch doof.
Wartet mal, das machen wir anders. Ich schmeiße das mal kurz hier in den Karton rein. Hier,
hier haben wir die zwei Schrauben, die wir brauchen anscheinend. Ja, Wärmeleitpaste
haben wir hier, guckt. Arctic Cooling MX5. Was auch immer, ihr seht das gar nicht, wenn
ich das einhalte. MX5. Haben die auch MX4 und MX6 und MX7 und... Gut, also wir sollen
den Kram hier dran schrauben, hat er gesagt. Also, hier, guckt mal. Moment, ihr seht das
gar nicht richtig, ne? Wartet mal, ich muss das anders machen, dass ihr das sehen könnt.
Ja, das ist scheiße. Wie mache ich denn das jetzt? Okay Leute, Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz,
ich muss mal, muss hier nebenbei ein bisschen Platz machen. Ich muss mal kurz hier nebenbei
ein bisschen abräumen, da liegt zum Beispiel eine Kamera drauf und sowas. Die muss weg.
Da liegt ein Beschriftungsgerät. Der alte Labelchamp. Nicht der neue. Der neue, den
kennt ihr ja noch aus dem Stream. Ein bisschen Platz machen, dass ich Platz habe, dass ich
die Kühlrippen da drauf legen kann. Oh, guckt mal. Da haben wir einen Raspberry Pi Zero
gefunden. Ne, das ist kein Zero, das ist ein Pico. Ach gut, den braucht keiner. Den Zero
hätte ich lieber gefunden. Guck mal. Stufenbohrer, was da alles rumliegt hier neben. Okay, nice.
A nice zoom. Jetzt habe ich Platz. Platz habe ich Platz. Es ist aber auch unhandlich das
Teil, Mann. Okay, jetzt, jetzt sieht man was. Pock, nice. Okay, ich muss nur gucken, dass
ich das nicht runterschmeiße. Das wäre nämlich echt not so Pock, wenn ich das runterschmeiße.
Okay, also was hat der Typ gesagt? Wir sollen das nehmen und hier dran schrauben. Sekunde,
das muss ich mir gerade noch mal anschauen. Okay, ja easy, easy. Okay, also Wasserkühlung,
also so rum. So rum muss das drauf, weil ich das jetzt gesehen habe. Machen wir das doch
so einfach mal. Also, wo habe ich die Schraube? Da. So, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehen
habe, muss das da einfach rein, oder? Einfach, einfach so im Endeffekt. Ich habe den falschen
genommen. Okay, easy, dran ist es. Andere Seite. Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum die unten
noch keine Werbeleitpaste drauf haben. Das ist, dass Leute mit dicken Fingern wie ich,
die da permanent drauf rumgreifen, das nicht am Finger hängen haben. Next. Gut, so, ich
glaube, ich muss noch ein bisschen fester machen, weil ich nicht weiß, wie fest man
es, man muss es ja nicht durch. Gut, da hätten wir das. Next, da müssen wir das Video weiter
schauen. Also, ich vermute mal, dass wir jetzt als nächstes den, die Platte, die Platte
drauf machen müssen. Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal voraus. Schauen wir mal weiter. Ja, mach
mal gleich, mach mal gleich. Das machen wir jetzt noch nicht. Ja. Nö, das sollte passen.
Das sollte passen. Porgo. Porgo. Jetzt dreht er durch. Ja, ich glaube, ich muss das jetzt
wieder durch hier. Ja, weiter. Auf, auf. Wollen wir das nächstes machen? Backplate. Jawoll.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Verstehe ich.
So kommt das da drunter? Das, das geht auch überhaupt nicht. Warte mal. Das geht auch
so überhaupt nicht. Da ist doch die andere Platte drunter. Muss man die andere Platte
vorher abmachen? Dann hätte ich mir das jetzt ja auch sparen können, das Ganze drauf. Keg
auf. Nee, nee, der setzt das Hochkante drauf, das Mainboard.
Aber der hat es auch dran auf der Rückseite. Sonst, sonst, der hat das gleiche Board wie
ich. Guck mal, der hat das gleiche Board wie ich. Guck mal, der hat es auch drauf. Der
hat es auch drauf, das muss man nicht abmachen. Das muss man nicht abmachen. Wie viel hat
das Board gekostet? Ich glaube 340 Euro. Das ist noch eines der günstigeren, wenn man
sich überlegt, das 43 Euro günstiges Keg. Okay, okay, okay, okay, das hätte ich jetzt
gar nicht gedacht. Okay, easy. Okay, das kriege ich hin. Also, die Nuts, wo sind die Nuts?
Wo sind die Nuts? Da, da sind die Nuts. Okay, also wenn ich jetzt richtig verstanden
hab, wir nehmen jetzt das Ding und machen hier unten die Teile durch, oder? Oh, fuck, es
runtergefallen, wo ist es hin? Monka. Okay, ich hab's wieder. So. Ah ja, ah ja, okay,
so halten die Dinger, so halten die Dinger alleine. Mach ich das, mach ich das richtig?
Nee, oder? Leute, hä? Wie soll das funktionieren?
Hab ich da irgendwas übersehen? Muss ich da irgendwas? Okay, der hat vorher die Abstandshalter
drum gemacht. Aber das hier, Moment, das muss doch so funktionieren. Guck, der hat die Dinger
hier reingemacht, so und dann hat er die irgendwie hier so. Aber das hält doch gar nicht. Das
hält doch gar nicht. Und kurz angucken. Gummi drauf? Der hat da keine Gummi-Ringe drauf
gemacht. Der hat die Gummi, der hat, der hat den Kram um. Ach so, ah, warte mal, das hab
ich nicht gesehen. Ach so, ah. Ach so. Ah, das hab ich gar nicht richtig mitgekriegt.
Ach so, dann ist die Gummi-Ringe drüber. Easy. Ja dann. Ja dann, ja dann ist klar, was das
nicht hält. Okay, Gummi-Ringe. Ja. Gummi-Ringe. Also sprich, man macht das durch, weil es
schwierig ist, wenn ich das jetzt drum halten muss. Man macht das quasi durch und dann
macht man den Gummi-Ringe drüber. Okay, das ist ein bisschen gefummelt, aber das funzt.
Ja, guck mal, jetzt hält das bei mir auch. Jetzt hält das bei mir auch. Okay, Gummi-Ringe
drüber. Nächster, nächster Gummi-Ringe. Du musst sie ins äußere Loch. Okay, werde
man gleich, werde ich gleich nochmal überprüfen. Muss ich mal kurz gucken, welches Loch der
das eingebaut hat. Ah, ins äußere tatsächlich. Okay, ich hätte es jetzt ins innere Fass
gemacht. Okay, okay, nice, nice. Gut zu wissen. Zum Glück haben die auch ein paar Ersatzteile
dabei für Leute wie mich, die es nicht checken. Kegweight. Willst du nur Windows auf dem PC
installieren? Was heißt nur? Was meinst du? Du meinst, ob ich Linux-Dualboot machen werde?
Nee. Ich werde Linux wieder in der VM betreiben, fertig aus. Genauso, wie ich das jetzt auch
mache. Ich muss kurz mal das mit den Schrauben um-um vorstellen.
Okay Leute, ich hab's. Okay. So, die zwei sind dran. Brauchen wir noch die nächsten
hier. Ja, guck, da, zack, rein damit, zack, in die Ecke. Ja, jetzt hab ich's. Das blöde
ist, wenn man das raus hat, dann muss das erst wieder in 5 Jahren machen und dann ist
die Montage wahrscheinlich wieder anders. Ja. Ring. Okay. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
gut, so. Unsere Mounting Plate ist da. Wie läuft Linux mit VM, mit VM bei Workstation,
ja? Okay, schalten wir mal kurz rein, was der jetzt als nächstes macht. Warum ich ja
anders heiße, weil ich einen anderen Account, weil ich einen Account schon angelegt hab,
bevor ich eigentlich selbst streamen wollte. Okay, das müssen wir jetzt machen, diese
komischen, äh, kleinen Plastik-Nippel da drauf machen. Okay. Und dann? Ja, okay. Okay,
dann die Backplate hinlegen. Ja. Aha. Okay, versteh ich, versteh ich. Alles klar. So,
das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt erstmal diese Dinger hier. Diese komischen Plastik, Plastik-Teile,
so und die macht man jetzt wie? Einfach? Wenn ich das richtig kenne, einfach über die
Löcher. Quasi. Quasi so. So, über die Löcher. Wofür braucht man das, dass man das Mainboard
nicht verkratzt mit den Schrauben oder was ist der, was ist der Sinn davon? Weil wirklich
groß Abstand machen die doch nicht, oder? Jetzt irgendwie großartigen Abstand hast du
dadurch doch nicht, oder? Die unten hin, die anderen oben? Das ist egal.
Oben und unten muss man die Dinger hin machen. Gut, ja. Andere Seite. Ja. Okay. Okay, das
ist gut. So. Jetzt machen wir da noch welche. Okay, die Dinger sind scheiße auszurichten,
wird schon passen. So. Sehr gut, passt genau. Aha, das ist das mal nichts mit den Schrauben
kaputt macht auf dem Mainboard. So, der Rest ist Reserve. Okay. Und jetzt soll ich, hat
man da gesagt, das da unten hinlegen. So. Und dann das Mainboard nehmen. Das Mainboard
nehmen wir so rum. So. Waren wir mal so. Jetzt sollen wir gucken. Aha. Schaut mal. Äh.
Pogu. Oder not so Pog. Habe ich die Schraube nicht richtig dran? Habe ich die Schraube
nicht richtig angesetzt bei dem einen oben in der Ecke? Oh nee, oder? Sack. Kann sein,
dass die Schraube nicht ganz in der Ecke ist. Achte auf die Pfeile. Äh. Achso. Wait a
moment. Nee, das ist richtig rum. Ich hab's, ich hab's, ich, ich hab's, ich hab's richtig
parallel. Jaja, ich hab's richtig rum. Ich hab's richtig, ich hab's richtig. Äh, ich
glaube, ich glaube, ich hatte die eine Schraube nicht, nicht richtig drin. Man sieht ja auch
ganz klar, welche nicht passt. Okay. Nochmal, nochmal schauen. Hä? Passt denn das nicht?
Habe ich die Schraube, habe ich die Schraube doch nicht an der richtigen? Okay. Also auf
jeden Fall die Schraube oben da hier, die in der Ecke, die, die passt nie richtig. Okay,
ich mach die nochmal ab. Guck, ob ich die nicht richtig in der Ecke setzen hab. Ja,
kann sein, dass die nicht richtig in der Ecke sitzt. Ja, die wird nicht richtig in der Ecke
setzen. Not so Pogge. Boah, ist das ein Gefurde. Okay, jetzt sitzt sie glaube ich richtig.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es gut. Jetzt, jetzt müsste es passen. Aha, es passt. Glaub ich
zumindest. Ich mein, das liegt ein bisschen schäpp hier. Nee, sieht gut aus. Gut. Wisst
ihr was? Wir müssen die Unterlage raus machen. Woop, Leak in der Batterie. Oh nein. Wir müssen
die Unterlage weg machen, dass das mal wirklich gerade ist hier. Ansonsten ist das, ansonsten
ist das Müll. Jetzt hier das, machen wir alles da oben hin. Wärmeleitpaste und das
Zeug brauchen wir gleich noch. Schmeiß ich mal weg. Legen wir das mal hier hin. Ich brauch
mal irgendwas zum Sammeln von so kleinen Kram. Perfekt. Gut, also jetzt das ganze nochmal.
Joa, gleich viel besser. Ja, Klick Klick hat es gemacht. Klick Klick Klick. Okay gut,
aber wie gehts weiter? Wie gehts weiter? Ja, haben wir, haben wir. Standoffs? Okay.
All the way muss gescrewt werden. Erdungsarmband hab ich am, an der Wade. Oh, ich greif auch
mal an die Heizung Leute, alles gut. Okay. Was krieg ich auf die Reihe? Okay, das machen
wir jetzt gleich. Also, gehen wir mal weitermachen. Also jetzt brauch ich die Abstandshalter,
wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab. Das sind die Dinger. Und die werden reingescrewt.
Abstandshalter. Der hat nichts von anziehen gesagt. Der schraubt das alles nur mit den
Fingern, oder? Oder zieht dann noch irgendwie großartig was an. Das hab ich jetzt nicht
gesehen. Naja, kaputt machen eher nicht, aber das halt am Ende nicht richtig kühlt. Ich
glaub, kaputt machen kann man jetzt nicht wirklich so viel, weil man nicht gerade das
rein rammt. Also wie gesagt, ich drehs nur mit dem Finger
fest, das müsste ja reichen, ne?
Warum nicht geerdet sein? Nee, da machst du in der Regel nichts kaputt, bis du halt mal
was kaputt machst. So, jetzt gucken wir uns das ganze mal von unten an. Das sieht auch
ganz gut aus, ne? So, wir sollen gucken, ob die Abstände passen. Ich würd jetzt mal so
als Kackknub sagen, ja die Abstände passen.
Jetzt machen wir wieder die Antistatikunterlage drunter. Nicht so sehr wegen Antistatik, sondern
weil ich ein bisschen draufdrücken muss gleich. Zum Gummi praktischer ist. Gut, jetzt haben
wir das. Das heißt, jetzt brauchen wir Wärmeleitpaste. Das ist ein alter Tisch aus dem Schrank, ob
das Ding verkratzt, ist vollkommen irrelevant. Okay, draufgespritzt. Ja, ich hab die Standoffs
benutzt aus dem Kit. Das teste ich vorher mal, bevor ich Wärmeleitpaste draufmache. Und
das Klebepad abmachen. Tighten evenly. Äh, was für Dinger brauch ich da jetzt? Ah, die
Dinger. Die dicken. Die dicken brauch ich jetzt. Hab ich hier. Ja, die sind auch dick. Hat
er, Leute, habt ihr aufgepasst? Hat er die nachgedreht mit dem Schraub? Ja, hat er nachgedreht.
Okay, mach ich auch jetzt gleich. So, ich teste jetzt erstmal, ob das funktioniert mit dem
draufsetzen, bevor ich Wärmeleitpaste draufmache. Okay, gut, gut, gut. Okay, das krieg ich hin.
Alles klar, auf geht's. Next. Gucken wir mal. Also, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob jetzt alles
passt. Ich muss das mal rumdrehen. Nee. Also, das Ding ist wirklich mega fett, Alter. Ist
auch unglaublich schwierig zu handeln. Okay. Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt draufpasst.
Muss ich das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen runterrutschen. Okay, das müsste da... Wo schließen wir dann
überhaupt hier das Kabel an für RGB und für... So, das hier ist das RGB-Kabel und das hier
ist das Kram für... So, da bleibt eigentlich nicht so viel übrig. Ich muss das dann quasi
an CPU-Fan eigentlich anschließen, oder? An CPU-Fan kommt es dran. Und hier oben kommt
es an LED dran. DLED 1, DLED 2. Ja, und hier unten kommt die Grafikkarte dran. Okay. Ich
kann keine Wasserkühlung empfehlen. Das ist die erste Wasserkühlung, die ich habe. Ich
weiß, dass ich das Board nicht abhabe, Leute. Ihr müsst jetzt nicht Panik kriegen. Ich will
nur mal schauen. Mist, Alter. Muss doch umdrehen. Oh, was geht mit der Musik ab, man? Was geht
mit der Musik ab? Ach, das ist wenn... Das ist mit Shopkeeper. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ist
Ach krass, dass das mir grad zu anstrengt
Okay Leute, ich hab ein Problem
Ich, das ist so weit weg, also ich krieg das nicht richtig drauf
Das Ding ist zu groß, mann
Okay, wie...
Ich leg das, ich leg das jetzt einfach so
Ich leg das jetzt so, was anderes fällt mir nicht ein
So, wie rum kommt denn das jetzt am besten drauf?
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich machs ja noch gar nicht drauf
Ich guck nochmal, ob's theoretisch passen würde
Okay, würde passen, alles klar
Ja, gut, würde passen
Würde passen
Oder?
Durch, durch welche Löcher macht er das durch?
Hier, ne, durch die hätte ich mal besser aufpassen sollen
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass ich noch keine Wärmeleitpaste drauf hab
Ne, das sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus
Ey, so, doch, okay, doch Leute, so würde das, so würde das passen
So würde das, so würde das passen
Jetzt halt die Frage, wie rum macht man den am besten drauf?
Weil dieser Lüfter hier soll ja ein bisschen RAM und, und Spannungswandler kühlen
Macht das nen Unterschied, wie, also hat das irgendwie nen Sinn?
Was hat er denn im Video gesagt?
Das ist nicht sonderlich lautes Ding, ne
Ich muss mir nochmal kurz ins Video gucken, wie er das jetzt eingebaut hat
Er hat den Lüfter quasi am Rand, wo die, ah Moment, Moment, der hat's wirklich andersrum
Der hat das, der hat, der hat den Lüfter in die Richtung
Letztendlich passt es aber noch in beide Richtungen drauf, oder? Weil ich mein, der Abstand
Oder passt es nicht?
Oder passt es nicht in beide Richtungen drauf? Also, theoretisch schon
Doch, ist richtig, so, der hat, der hat das da, wo ich auch drauf hab
Okay, aber er hat's, er hat's auf jeden Fall andersrum als ich drauf
Wozu man den CPU-Kontakt-Frame benötigt? Man benötigt den gar nicht
Das ist nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass deine CPU ein bisschen gekrümmt ist
Dass es besser am Kühler anliegt, eigentlich Spielerei
Okay, also ich muss das Ding quasi
Na super, wie montiere ich ihn das jetzt? Andersrum hätte es ja noch fast funktioniert, aber
Na gut, ich muss das Mainboard rumdrehen, Leute, anders geht nicht, ich muss das Mainboard rumdrehen
So
Also so rum, oder? Alter, ist das ein, ja, okay, das passt
Das ist ja eh nur zum Testen jetzt, ja? Okay, nice, gut
So, Wärmeleitpaste, wo bist du?
Moin, Chandler
Ich hab noch kein Gehäuse, das ist doch die Sache, mein Gehäuse kommt erst morgen, ich wollte aber schon mal ausprobieren
Wo bläst denn dieser Lüfter überhaupt hin? Der bläst hier raus
So, der bläst hier quasi auf die Spannungswandler und das ganze Zeug
Man könnte ihn auch auf die SSD blasen lassen, Leute, wisst ihr, ich glaube im Prinzip, das macht gar keinen großen Unterschied
Wahrscheinlich nicht, so, wir montieren das Ding jetzt, also
Wärmeleitpaste, gib ihm, und nicht umfallen dahinten, ne?
Okay, Wärmeleitpaste
Drauf spritzen
Ich auferklocke da nichts, das ist mir schnell genug, ja, Wärmeleitpaste
Wir machen da nicht ganz so viel drauf wie der Typ, machen wir hier so ein
So, das muss reichen, weil
Wenn man da drauf drückt, dann versteilt sich das eh über die ganze CPU, also
Mehr? Warum?
Okay, weil ihr seid, ich mache jetzt für euch noch links und rechts einen Klecks hin
Normalerweise mache ich das übrigens gar nicht so, normalerweise mache ich die mit den Klecks und drücke das einfach möglichst fest drauf und gut ist
Ne, das reicht, Leute, das reicht, das reicht
Zumal ich es wahrscheinlich eh abmachen muss morgen, zumindest Gehäuse einbauen
Oder nehme ich auch die andere Wärmeleitpaste, also insofern
So ausprobieren ist das gut genug, okay, Pad ist ab
Nice
Gut
Es pappt, wo habe ich die Dinger hier?
Alter
Kommst nicht dran
Das ist scheiße, ich sehe das nicht, Leute, bin ich drauf? Seht ihr was? Ja, scheint zu passen
Jetzt ein bisschen festschrauben hier
Unten auch
Ihr seht auch nichts, da sind wir schon zu zweit
Sehen alle nichts
Not, not, not, not seeing hier
Hier kommt man ja wirklich scheiße rein, man
Alter, kommt in die Kacke rein in die Ecke, hoffe das passt jetzt
Dann titeln wir das mal
Okay
Kein lag, sollte kein lag sein, wenn lag, dann macht Vodafone wieder komische Dinger
Wisst ihr, dafür ist dieser Schraubendreher mega praktisch, guck, der kann nämlich, seht ihr
Das so mit Ratschenfunktion, oh eben habe ich auch ein bisschen laggen sehen, das lag an der Kameraübertragung
Okay
Ich würde sagen
Gatschi passt, das Ding ist drauf
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie fest man das anziehen muss, aber ganz im Ernst, Leute, ich denke
Wenn man das so aus dem Handgelenk
Aus dem Handgelenk festzieht
Das sollte eigentlich mehr als ausreichen
170 Newtonmeter, ja ist klar, ich hole erstmal meinen 2 Meter Schlüssel
So, fertig
Wir haben es angeschlossen
Ich bin gespannt, Leute
Achso, der RAM fehlt noch, okay, die Wärmerleit passt, dann machen wir mal weg
Wir legen das mal, ich will das nicht, dass mir das aufs Mainboard fällt, klar
Weil das Netzteil muss ja auch noch dahin irgendwie
Gucken, wie wir das machen mit dem Netzteil
Ja, für kurzfristig reicht das mal so
Netzteil lege ich hier unten hin, Leute, Netzteil lege ich dahin, hier auf die Seite
So, jetzt haben wir das dran, alles klar, alles gut, RAM, RAM muss noch rein
RAM
Natürlich doof jetzt, dass ich das hier nicht richtig drücken kann
Da kann man das nicht richtig draufdrücken wegen diesen Dingen unten drunter
Müssen wir es so mal von Hand machen
Leute, ich bin da tatsächlich diesmal echt sehr vorsichtig, was das angeht
Oh, oh, oh, ich glaube ich habe es falsch rum, Leute
Bald hätte ich dem Ding eine zweite Kerbe verpasst, oder?
Ja, so ist gut
Blode Game, Dankeschön für den Zapp
So, wir sind fertig
Jetzt müssen wir das Netzteil anschließen, an dem Moment hier, RGB, RGB
Also, Lüfter, CPU, Lüfter
CPU, Fan
Und RGB
Ist das richtig?
Äh
Sekunde
Kurz kontrollieren, ich sehe es nicht richtig
Ja, ist richtig
Okay, gut
Mal den Kram hier irgendwie ein bisschen aus dem Weg packen, so ums RAM drum herum oder sowas
Hier, ja, perfekt
Gut, alles dran, alles drin
Grafikkarte machen wir nachher vielleicht, mal gucken, zum angehen ist das ja nicht wirklich wichtig
Das ist ja eine, äh, 1300K, da ist eine Grafikkarte drin
Ich will erst mal wissen, was das angeht
So, wo ist der Power Knopf? Was ist der Power Knopf? Das da? Nee
Wo ist der Power Knopf? Das da? Reset Switch, das da, das ist der Power Knopf hier
Das glaube ich der Power Knopf
Da steht zwar Reset dran, aber das haben wir in letztem Handbuch nachgeguckt
Das ist kein Reset Switch, das ist Power On, Power Off, der aus irgendwelchen Gründen Reset heißt
Die GPU wird erst beim Gehäuse eingebaut, nee, nicht unbedingt, nicht unbedingt
Mal gucken, mal gucken
In der Lage geht es halbwegs, da zieht nicht so viel am PCI Express Slot
Aber nehmen wir erst mal das Netzteil
So, Netzteil ist hier
Das kann ich hier nicht hinlegen, Leute, das Netzteil lege ich hier unten hin, das seht ihr jetzt nicht
Ihr werdet es verkraften, Netzteile sind nicht so spannend
So, wir brauchen einen Anschluss
Also SATA Kabel brauchen wir nicht
Ein Kaltgerätestecker brauchen wir aber
Den stecke ich schon mal hier oben in die Steckdose
So, und führ das mal hier vorbei, dass es nicht im Weg ist
Aber ich stecke es noch nicht ein
So
Wir brauchen ATX Stecker
Keine Klettverschlüsse, kein Overclocking Button, wo ich immer noch nicht weiß wofür der da ist
Main ATX Connector, den brauchen wir
Ich brauch keine Kabelbinder und keine komischen Klettverschlüsse
Main ATX Connector brauchen wir
Da ist er hier
Der Main ATX Connector
Ich muss jetzt mal ins Netzteil reinstecken
Welche Seite kommt denn da ans Mainboard und welche kommt denn ans Netzteil?
So rum, hm?
Na gut, es ist glücklicherweise so gebaut, dass es eigentlich nur in eine Richtung reinpasst
Insofern kann man da nicht viel verkehrt machen
OK
Also ATX Stecker haben wir
OK, ist auch lang genug
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch 8-Pin-Power-Connector
Da
Seht ihr nicht, weil der Chat dabei ist, aber das ist unwichtig da unten
8-Pin-Power-Connector
Nee, das ist Grafikkartenkabel
Das ist was anderes, das brauche ich jetzt nicht
Hier, hier, da habe ich es richtig
8-Pin-Power-Connector
VGA
ICPU
8-Pin
OK
Gut
Muss man? OK, ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man beide anschließen muss, aber weißt du was?
Ich schließe einfach mal beide an, schadet ja nichts
8-Pin
Oder muss man dann nur einmal anschließen?
Wie sieht denn der Stecker aus?
Stecker sieht so aus, OK
Also ans Mainboard dran
Hier
B8
Ja, das Mainboard steht ein bisschen wackelig, muss ich mal aufpassen
Machen wir das mal so, dass es hier nicht
B8
OK
Das machen wir anders, das legen wir da drauf, so ist gut
So, ich hätte noch einen zweiten
Ich schließe mal beide an, ganz ehrlich
Schaden kann es anscheinend nichts
Ja
Das ist auch dran, den machen wir auch aus dem Weg
Sehr gut
Gut, jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch ATX Power Connector
Und wir sind good to go
Den sehe ich jetzt nicht, ihr seht ihn, sagt mir wenn ich richtig bin oder falsch bin
Ihr seht auch nichts, oder?
Na das ist ja toll
Wir sehen alle nichts, optimal, optimum hier
Keiner sieht was
Aber wenn er nichts sieht, macht es am meisten Spaß, GachiBuzz
OK, ich glaube das ist drin
Ich sehe es nicht richtig, aber ich glaube es ist
Alles drin, kurz gucken
Jaja
Ich sehe halt echt nichts da hinten in der Ecke
Und wir sind ready
So hier
Das machen wir auch da drunter
Da drunter, da drunter
So, OK
Ready
Dann schalten wir mal ein würde ich sagen
HDMI, ne wir schalten einfach mal ein und gucken ob er angeht
Das reicht erst mal
Gucken ob er angeht
Ob die Lüfte angehen
OK, bevor ich einschalte Leute, noch mal kurz
Gehen wir noch mal kurz in uns
SSD
Kann es nichts falsch machen
Kühler
Keine Ahnung, kann es wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel falsch machen, ich habe jetzt ja alles dran
Muss man da irgendwo noch was rausziehen oder so, ne glaub nicht
Hier ist nichts, angeschlossen ist alles an Strom, eigentlich war es das
OK
Strom dran
Oh ne, warte
Komm her
Moment, ich muss das Netzteil hier erst mal hinlegen
Sackt ein bisschen so
Guck mal hier, da sind wir hingeblieben
Will das jetzt aus dem Weg, sonst sehe ich ja gar nichts
OK, wir machen an
Kabel rein
OK, Netzteil an
Es hat geplinkt Leute
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
Plinkchamp
Und jetzt, den da drücken oder?
Oh ho
Monkeys
Leute
Es läuft
Easy
Nice
Kluckert oder so?
Nö
Ist durchaus OK
Bläst ordentlich
Der Kollege hier bläst auch ein bisschen
Jetzt ist er aus, das war ich nicht
Achso, der rebootet immer mal wieder
Auch immer RGB am Start
Gachi-Fan
Nice
Hier unten ist übrigens auch RGB, man sieht es ja nicht richtig am Mainboard
Hat keinen tieferen Sinn
Die True Gaming Experience, yup
Leute, soll ich Capture Card anschließen und wir gucken zusammen mal, ob er bootet?
Ach komm, machen wir
Ich mache Strom aus
Strom ist aus, eigentlich sollte er ja ausgehen, Strom ist aus
Die RGB Lüfter haben keinen Bock auszugehen
Ah jetzt
Ich musste Capture Card aus dem Schrank holen
Sack
Warte, wo habe ich
Ohne Case
So, ich habe eine Capture Card, ich muss die mal kurz anschließen
Die hat ein bisschen Lag, werdet ihr gleich sehen, aber nicht allzu schlimm
Also für euch, wobei ihr merkt es eh nicht, ob das laggt oder nicht
Könnt ihr nicht merken, weil ihr habt keinen Input Vergleich
Mal gucken, wie ich das jetzt hier anschließe
Nice
Oh, Capture Card
Das wird ein bisschen schwierig jetzt
Das hinzubekommen, muss ich mal schauen, wie wir das machen
Also Capture Card
So, Game Capture
Macht das jetzt was?
Ich mach euch mal kurz um, dass ihr seht, was passiert
One Moment
Ok, die Capture Card entdeckt, das ist schon mal gut
Signal zu detekten gibt es aktuell keins
Ich schließe es mal an
Ich hoffe das Kabel reicht, das ist jetzt wirklich ein bisschen abenteuerlich hier
Ja, das reicht, easy, reicht dicke
Capture, wo ist Hdmi?
Hdmi ist hier unten
Ok, Hdmi ist dran, ich schalte ein, mal gucken, ob ein Bild kommt
Pause Champ
Ok
Erleuchtet
Wenn es nicht geht, kann er immer noch an der Capture Card liegen
Elgato Lul
Nordpog
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der funktioniert, er wird ja sonst im Post schon hängen
Weil RGB und alles geht an
Ich glaube einfach, dass das Capture Programm sackt
Und wiederum spackt
Oder die Capture Card
Kein Low-Res
Irgendwie verkraftet
Capture
Monitor dran hauen, oh nee, da muss ich jetzt umstöpseln
Ja, da startet neu zwischendurch, weil er kein Betriebssystem findet, also
Oh, habe ich es überhaupt richtig eingestöpselt? Moment, ist das überhaupt am richtigen Eingang?
Sekunde Leute
Ja, ja, ja, ja, alles gut
Gut
Vielleicht ist das HDMI Kabel auch im Arsch
Ah, ah
Der ist einfach nur lahmarsch Champ
Alles klar, da sind wir
So wirklich viel machen können wir jetzt nicht, weil ich will meine Tastatur eigentlich
Okay, komm, wir sind mal nicht so
Wie kriege ich denn die Tastatur jetzt da gescheit rüber?
Bios Update, der kann kein Bios Update machen, das ist kein Netzwerk und nichts dran
Okay, Tastatur
Wie kriege ich die Tastatur da jetzt rüber gescheit?
Sekunde, muss ich mal entwirren
Die ist nicht dafür gemacht hier groß rum
Okay
Dann Leute, Tastatur
Wir haben es gleich
Gut, dass ich aufgeräumt habe vor ein paar Tagen, jetzt kann man das hier alles halbwegs bewegen
Okay, Tastatur anstöpseln
Hier an irgendeinem USB
Tastatur, okay
Guck mal, wir hätten sogar Maus im Bios
Das ist nice, ich habe doch hier noch irgendwo eine Maus rumliegen, Leute
Wartet mal, ich habe doch noch eine Ersatzmaus hier am anderen Rechner
Jetzt habe ich euren Chat zugemacht, Leute
Weil ich sinnlos rumgeklickt habe
Leute, ich bin dumm, ich habe doch noch meine alte, wo habe ich die denn hin?
Die habe ich mir immer auf den Dachboden geschmissen, so wie ich mich kenne
Ich habe doch noch meine alte, die liegt doch hier noch irgendwo
Ich habe doch die, die ich ausgetauscht habe, ich habe eigentlich noch eine zweite Tastatur
Ich muss mal kurz die zweite Maus entwirren
Maus, weirdchamp, wirechamp ist es in dem Fall jetzt
Okay, ich habe eine Maus, alles klar
Okay, zwei Mäuse, die fast identisch aussehen, was kann denn da schon schief gehen?
Also ich zeige es euch mal hier, guck mal, hier sind wir
Hier sind wir
Achso, ich habe gerade auf der Tastatur umgeschaltet, das geht ja nicht, die ist ja gar nicht an dem Rechner dran
Gut, hoho, Leute, es bewegt
Ich habe übrigens Input-Lag
BIOS mit Maus bedienen, das ist echt weirdchamp
Okay, der CPU-Fan ist am fennen
Gehen wir hier weg
Was haben wir denn da?
Wir haben ein Z790 Elite F2
Mit dem 13900K, 64GB RAM
Memory-Frequency, MonkaS, da stimmt aber was nicht
Ach, XMP disabled, XMP an müssen wir machen
Kann man direkt BIOS-Update machen, aus dem BIOS
Dann schließe ich nämlich mal ein Netzwerkkabel an
Wir machen ein BIOS-Update, Leute, ich schließe mal ein Netzwerkkabel an
Jaja, jaja, Moment, da muss ich den Switch anschließen
Aber da habe ich keinen
Oh, Netzwerkkabel
Ich versuche euch mal kurz umzuschalten
So sieht es aus
Netzwerkkabel, klicke die, klick
Da hinten ist der Switch
Hat auch schon Link
Excellent
100 MBit Link, nice
Aber gut, wir sind im BIOS, da verzeihe ich das mal
Massive Highspeed
So, also, woher weiß ich jetzt?
F8 muss ich drücken
No Disk Found, alles klar
Advanced Mode, F2
Easy Mode
Ok Leute, wie flasht man das jetzt?
Flasht man das überhaupt aus dem BIOS?
Tweaker Settings
Sys Info
Q-Flash
No Disk Found
Nope
Kann das vielleicht nicht flashen?
Kann das nicht über das Internet flashen?
Vielleicht kann das nicht über das Internet flashen
Ihr müsst mal googeln für mich, ich habe keine Möglichkeit, weil ich meine Tastatur abgestöpselt habe
Googelt mal, Gigabyte Z790 BIOS Flash oder so
Gigabyte kann das nicht
Na gut, wie oft braucht man das?
Also was haben wir jetzt zu bieten?
Enhanced Multi-Core Performance, Auto Auto, CPU Base Clock, Auto Auto, ich lasse erstmal alles auf Auto
Extreme Memory Profile, das machen wir aber an
Och was jetzt?
Profile 1, yep, yep cock, jawoll, das sieht gut aus
Mordsbandmann Nico, sowas hasse ich, übel sweetie pest
So, was haben wir als nächstes? Nee, das brauchen wir nicht
Gut, das ist richtig so
Das ist richtig so, der hat das Profil geladen
VTD machen wir an, ich will VM machen, ich will Virtualisierung Scramble machen
Ihr könnt einen Tag Timeout machen oder einen Tag Bann oder so, aber sowas triggert mich immer übertrieben
Ich habe da echt keinen Bock drauf, was lesen zu müssen, so klugscheißer Kram
Was ist VTD? Das ist Intel Virtualisierungstechnologie, da kannst du beispielsweise VM oder Virtual Box betreiben
Du mein, du kannst das theoretisch auch ohne betreiben, aber es geht schneller
Dank diesem Kram ist es sicherer zu virtualisieren und vor allem ist es nahezu Native Performance
Also du wirst heutzutage keinen Unterschied merken, wenn du einen CPU intensiven Benchmark in der VM laufen lässt und auf dem haust
Das ist im Prinzip Messungenauigkeit mittlerweile
Was kommt für ein OS drauf? Windows
Wegen Videobearbeitung, Gaming, Stream, aber Linux in der VM, deswegen schalte ich das ein
So, Data Controllers Enabled, Enhanced Multi-Core Performance
Guck dir mal, Enhanced Multi-Core Performance ist da oben und ganz oben ist noch mal Enhanced Multi-Core Performance
Ich lasse das alles mal auf Auto
Um BIOS zu upgraden, benutze ich sowohl Gigabit-Q-Flash als auch Q-Flash-Plus-Utility
Q-Flash-Plus-Utility lässt dich, BIOS zu updaten, wenn dein System off ist
Save die neuesten BIOS an USB
Ok, also will ich Q-Flash
Also muss ich das auf den USB-Stick machen
Das Menü wiederholt sich, ja
Hä, Alter, ach das sind Favorites, ach das sind Favorites
Ok, das ist Pepega, das hast du richtig blöd gemacht, Alter
CPU Upgrade, Disable All E-Cores for Gaming
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist ok
Base Clock Speed lassen wir alles, alles standardmäßig erstmal
Memory aber eigentlich, das lassen wir auch alles default
Wieso ist VTD eigentlich standardmäßig aus? Ich hab die Frage nicht genau gesehen, aber wahrscheinlich weil es die meisten Leute nicht brauchen
Ok, was haben wir hier zu bieten? Plattform Power?
Hab ich meine Maus bewegt?
Äh, ganz ehrlich
Ah, das ist wenn Strom, wenn Strom ausfällt, always off, always off
Ja, always on, lass mal, lass mal auf off
Lassen wir alles mal standard
Ich will Windows L fusing, ja
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich standardmäßig an
Initial Display Output, Internal Graphics
Ja
Network Stack Configuration
Ah, vielleicht kann man da noch was machen
Wobei, das dürfte wahrscheinlich eher sein für PXEboot und sowas
Network Stack Disabled
Enabled?
Das ist für PXEboot denke ich, ja, nee, nee, nee, das ist für PXEboot
Das hat mit BIOS, mit BIOS anscheinend nichts zu tun denke ich mal
Wir machen uns gleich einen USB Stick und flashen das noch
Ihr könnt ja mal weiter googlen, ob es nicht die Möglichkeit gibt, das noch zu aktualisieren
Ok, nee, nee, das ist für PXEboot, das brauche ich nicht, nicht daheim
Das Resizable Bar, was soll ich einstellen?
Samsung, ok, das ist die SSD
Was kann man da konfigurieren?
Achso, nö
egal
SATA konfigurieren, VMD Setup, was ist denn VMD?
Disable VMD Controller, ist das RGB?
Was ist denn der VMD Controller?
Ich kann da nicht gucken, weil ich die Tastatur nicht angeschlossen habe
Ok
Ach Intel Volume Management, Ach Raid Gedöns und sowas
Ne, das machen wir weg
Achso, ok Nico, ist gut, entbandt ihn wieder
Dann habe ich vielleicht den falschen Hals gekriegt, aber mich nicht, nervt sowas immer
Vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach falsch gelesen von dir, wie es gemeint ist
Hast du jetzt einen zweiten Account gemacht? Brauchst du nicht
Das ist wieder entbandt
Was ist denn das Gigabyte Download Utilities Configuration?
Legacy USB Supports
Gigabyte Utilities Downloader
What the fuck ist das bitte schön?
Was ist der Gigabyte Utilities Downloader?
Ist das China-Chinesen Backdoor oder wie?
Ich habe halt nichts wo ich googlen kann, meine Tastatur ist an dem Rechner angeschlossen
Ich heule jetzt mal kurz mein Tablet, dass ich was zum googlen habe
Ok
After you install operating dialog box will appear
Bottom right corner
Asking if you want to download and install a driver gigabyte application via gigabyte control
Warum braucht das?
Die sind schwach sind geh mal bloß weg, der soll nix von sich aus installieren
Geh mal fort
Ich mach das schon selbst
Piss dich alter genau
So ok, haben wir eigentlich alles eingestellt soweit
If system is resizable bar capable ich lasse es auf auto
PCI bifurcation support, wie man das ausspricht, da könnte man sogar noch extra, da könnte man quasi aus einem PCI express slot mehrere machen wenn man das will
Will man aber
In desktop geräten eher weniger
Ok haben wir alles wunderbar
CFG log bestimmt dass man Passwörter oder so braucht dafür
Windows 10 Features
Ok einfach Windows was
Ehrlich gesagt möchte ich am liebsten secure boot ausmachen
Hier unten ist secure boot
Geht veracrypt überhaupt mit Windows 11
Weil ohne wer ziemlich ja geht ok dann ist gut
Ok save und exit setup
Das ist gut man kriegt noch mal den Summary was man gemacht hat
Yes
Ok und nun
Und jetzt werde ich die Tastatur wieder umstöpseln
Und wir machen uns einen USB Stick
Den ich zum BIOS updaten
Verwenden kann
Das ist mega langsam zum booten guckt euch das mal an
Ok also
Was hat er jetzt ok aber das System ist jetzt auf 6400 und so alles klar
Ne das brauchen wir nicht BIOS wo ist das BIOS
BIOS
F5I
Ok
Das Gigabyte Control Center das werde ich mir nicht installieren sollte es sich irgendwie machen lassen
Fix RGB Fusion Issue
C4 Speed Internet Accelerator Software
Alter geh mal weg ich will mein Internet Speed nicht acceleraten
Lasst mich in Ruhe mit diesem Scheiß geht weg
Ok das brauchen wir also jetzt F5I was haben sie denn gemacht
Check Summ 0F36 ja ein exellentes Change Lock da weiß man sofort Bescheid
Improve Linkage between Resizable and 4G
Was auch immer Feintune CPU
Add CDR Bandwith Low Latency Option add CPU bis bis quits
Kann man darauf irgendwie was backen jetzt weil das so warm wird
Add Instant 6 Gigahertz Profile ja ja ist gut ok runterladen
Und wie geht das jetzt einfach auf den USB Stick ziehen oder PDF
Ach by the way das ist das falsche Mainboard was ihr mir gepostet habt
Mir auch gerade aufgefallen
AX Elite AX
Elite AX
Chipsets Intel
Chat was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem
Und dem so exakt das gleiche
Was ist der Plan ist BIOS Update zu machen
M ne
M hab ich nicht hab das normale
Ah das ist kleiner
Ok also
Boah die Seite man wer hat die gebaut
Specifications
Support
BIOS
F3G
Ah F2 haben wir drauf und F3G gibt es jetzt
Ah da ist es Check Summ 0EE1
Und der Rest ist irgendwie das gleiche alles klar ok
Also wie funktioniert das mit dem Flaschen
Download BIOS File from Gigabit Website und cp to the root directory of a bootable USB Flash Drive
Use USB Flash Drive to boot the shell in EFI Shell Mode
Oh High IQ Shit ist das jetzt
Kann man nicht einfach Q-Flash drücken
What
Was Summ
Ich kann das bestimmt auf den USB Stick zählen einfach Q-Flash drücken
Ich zähle das jetzt einfach auf den USB Stick und Gutes
Ja genau Bimmerzug so hätte ich das auch gemacht
Ok wieder am Start
Was ziehe ich denn jetzt raus
Das hier ist
Was kann ich denn rausziehen hier das da ich glaube das ist mein Mikro das brauche ich jetzt nicht
Ich habe extra einen alten USB 2 USB Stick genommen
Nein geht mir nicht auf den Keks
Ah Vo Plus Firmware ok ja die können wir löschen
Format FAT32 sollte man das irgendwie beschränken vielleicht hat es damit Probleme
Ok
Und gib ihm
Hoffen wir mal das es jetzt einfach funktioniert
Hoffen wir mal das es jetzt geht
Easy
Komm wir sind wir sind mal nett
Wichtig dass Windows bimimimim macht dabei
Alles klar dann checken wir mal ob wir da jetzt Flashen können
Du musst die BIOS Datei noch in Gigabyte Bin umbenennen
Seriously
Woher soll man das wissen
Ok Sekunde
Gigabyte QFlash
Download PDF User Guide ja wunderbar
Das ist das ist ja Antik man
Ich schiebe das jetzt einfach rein und Expekte dass es wirkt
Vielleicht auch zu viel Expected
Wo habe ich denn meine Maus hin
Nochmal
Ok
Update BIOS ja
Task
Und jetzt darauf klicken oder
High IQ File Manager hier
Are you are you sure
Wir sind sure
Ok das war jetzt einfach da muss man nichts umbenennen
Press to start
In order to make complete update system is going to shut down QFlash
Continue after restart
Ok
Wir warten und wir hoffen
Dass gleich wieder
Was erscheint
Force Champ Leute
Force Champ
Ah ne
Ne ne
F3G ist das aktuelle
Das davor war das falsche Board
Mit dem 5 war das falsche Board
Ok Leute was haben wir gemacht
Gigabyte Downloader aus
VTD eingeschaltet und XMP eingeschaltet
Merkt euch das mal please
Das müssen wir vielleicht nach dem Update nochmal neu einstellen
Wie wirst du die Lüfter steuern also ganz ehrlich
Gar nicht
Die sind absolut top gerade die sind direkt hier auf dem Tisch daneben super leise
Ist wirklich du hörst also es stört null
Gar nichts das ist nahezu silent du musst schon genau hinhören
Ich habe aktuell habe ich einen CPU Lüfter dran
Also ich habe die
Die Wasserkühlung Lüfter schon an dem an dem Pin für die für den CPU Lüfter dran
Hörst du was von der Pumpe
Nö
Nichts
Gar nichts
Ja dass es unter Last krach macht ist doch in Ordnung oder was heißt krach dass man unter
Last hört ist ja ok aber im Desktop Betrieb das ist doch das wichtige
Nein nein die ist fertig deswegen heißt es heißt es ja auch all in one
Weil du da nichts mehr machen musst
Wir könnten auch ein Windows 11 ISO flaschen mal auf den USB Stick gleich
Und dann wird das 11 Installation machen
Komm wir machen schnell noch wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit wir machen noch eine Windows 11 Installation
Da können wir schon mal die Tat dann machen wir einmal einmal machen wir einen kleinen Benchmark
Noch und gucken ob das so passt Benchmark stellt
Nee kein Arsch Arsch kommt wieder in die Vm
Ehrlich gesagt dachte ich mir das bis heute auch
Also bis zu dem PC mit der Wasserkühlung ich habe auch immer gesagt Luft
Aber diesmal dachte ich mir scheiß drauf die Dinger sind mittlerweile so gut ich glaube die geben sogar sieben Jahre Garantie
Also die müssen da schon irgendwie gewisses Vertrauen drin haben und das hat sich ja auch gezeigt
Wenn man so rumschaut die letzten Jahre über es gibt eigentlich so gut wie keine Probleme ist alles ok
Jetzt müsste es nur müsste es nur wieder angehen
Also Leute ich werde mich hüten das jetzt auszuschalten während der gerade BIOS Update gemacht hat
Aber es sieht noch alles gut aus
Wir können schon mal Windows 11 Download
Da hat es noch nicht
Dominos was Windows 11 Download
Gibt es die Dinger überhaupt noch
Jetzt herunterladen
Nein
Muss man wieder den gleichen Trick machen wie unter Windows
Ach ne Installationsmedium
Ah ISO
Hätte ich mal weiter gelesen
Aha da sind wir wieder
Anscheinend
Oder auch nicht
Eben waren wir auch kurz da
Jetzt sind wir wieder da
Ach der versucht immer noch BIOS zu flashen
Ne der ist im EFI hängen geblieben ok nice ich werde den USB Stick abziehen
Auswählen englisch please englisch international bestätigen
Gib mir nen ISO
Alter Residenz Sleeper Champ
Kann man hier nicht mal den Download Link kopieren
Warum kann man den Download Link nicht mehr kopieren
Muss man dazu irgendwie in Downloads
Copy Link
So langsam
Ich meine das geht noch eine Ecke schneller
Aber so viel schneller auch gar nicht mal ich habe nur 400 MBit
Guck mal 400 MBit in Megabytes sind was
50 ok da geht noch ein bisschen was
Ah gut die 5 Minuten haben wir jetzt auch noch
Die 5 Minuten haben wir jetzt auch noch
Ach ja
Leute
Ich bin ja
Wait a minute wie macht man das eigentlich unter Windows
Leute geht das unter Windows mittlerweile gescheit ansonsten lade ich es mir unter Linux runter und die DEDAS schnell drauf
Ach so ein Crap ich mache das unter Linux und DEDAS
Ich entzellehe mir dafür doch jetzt nichts
Ah
Es wird drauf die DEDAS Leute
Easy
Da kann man es auch
Alter geh weg da kann man es auch schneller downdownen
Ups
Wie ging das jetzt noch mal
ARIA 2
X16
War das X16
X16 und
Ah jetzt flutscht es
Oder auch nicht
Er hat gemerkt dass ich ihn jibade
Er hat den jibade durchschaut
Aber geht trotzdem noch schneller
Ok USB Stick
Blub blub blub blub
Connect Connect to Poggers
Das ist ein Download Manager der mehrere Verbindungen aufbauen kann
Das ist ganz nützlich
So also wo sind wir denn Attached wir sind Attached an
Fdisk-l def stb
Der hat 14 ja das passt
Wir können es mit Etcher
Komm Leute weil ihr es seid wir machen es mit dem GUI
Ansonsten hätte ich jetzt die DED
Für euch Chat
Für die Windows User unter euch
DED
Na gut
Also Leute sollen wir mit dem GUI flaschen
Etcher kann kein Windows wirklich nicht
Doch oder
Er macht keine Umfrage
Ich teste erstmal ob das mit Etcher geht
Das wird mich jetzt wundern wenn das nicht geht
Ich muss das jetzt testen weil der Chat gesagt hat das geht angeblich nicht
Das glaube ich nicht
Also DED würde folgendermaßen gehen
So DED
Input
Home
Max
Downloads
Ah ne ich bin direkt im Max
Win 11 ISO
OF
Gleich
Def
STB
Block Size
4 MB
Das wars
Mehr musst du nicht machen
Procrast ja du hast recht Procrast ist nicht verkehrt
Ja ja ja
Der Windows Media Creator wäre schon durch
Nö der Windows Media Creator wäre nicht durch
Weil der muss es auch noch downloaden
DED doesn't work
Wie man kann eine ISO falsch DEDen
Seriously
Alter Windows macht mich fertig ey
Mal gucken was Etcher sagt
Bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
Schein hat schon wieder daran irgendwie diesen Schrott überhaupt auf nur das B-Stick zu kriegen man
Oh Hammer kann man nicht erzählen
Ah wie
Hört mir auf zu sagen was ich nehmen soll Chat
Aber
Wie kann man was falsch DEDen ich meine man kann das ISO auf den USB Stick packen fertig
PC schon fertig gebaut
Das ist Betrachtungssache würdest du sagen so ist fertig
Würdest du sagen so ist fertig Moment so
Der schaltet nicht um
Würdest du sagen so ist fertig
Also wenn du das als fertig ansiehst dann sind wir fertig
Massive Airflow
So Flash From File Downloads
Ah ne wir sind ja gar nicht in Downloads
Missing Partition
It looks like this is not a bootable image
Oh Gott
Warum ist Windows eigentlich so scheiße und kann auch nicht mal geflasht werden einfach auf den USB Stick
Etcher Windows 11 ISO
Das muss doch auch gehen es muss doch Leute geben die unter Linux den Windows ISO erstellen wollen
Aber gibt es Rufus für Linux
El Nombre del Direct was Directorio
Man kann unter Linux keine Windows USB Boot erstellen
Kackel
Meine Fresse ist das wieder schlecht
Alter
Wenn toll bin
Wenn toll Windows ist wenn toll nicht dieser Multiboot USB Stick
Aha
Hab ich noch nie verwendet okay also das das möchte nicht
Okay okay die erklären uns das jetzt hier die erklären uns das jetzt
Alter Browser
Ja unter Windows Alter
Afrikaner Articles
Mein Browser ist ja mega am abscheißen warum brauchen das so viel Leistung im Hintergrund gerade
Das ist doch das was nicht geht
Das ist doch das was angeblich nicht geht
Alter die Chebaten
Die Chebaten
Der hat es einfach geflasht
Und bei ihm geht das
Warum geht das einfach bei ihm
Was ist das für Chebat
Warum kann er das warum kann er das flaschen und ich nicht
Was gibt es WoW USB
Es muss doch möglich sein unter Linux in einfachen Windows in Windows
Ah ja hier
Okay
NG
Okay wir installieren NG
Weil NG ist nicer
Crap
Wait a minute ich will keinen Crap installieren
NG ist ach es gibt es nicht oder was okay
NG ist ach NG ist gar nicht so NG oder wie man denkt
Also das ist das richtige
Crap
Warum um alles in der Welt will der Crap installieren
Ich will keinen Crap installieren
Alter ich kriege Anfälle ich will und okay Moment Moment
Snapshot
Und mit aber wenn was ist der Unterschied zwischen wenn toll und dem Ding
Okay
Ja gut installieren wir Crap vielleicht macht er schon an mich gar nichts
Mr. Godfrey du musst davon ausgehen dass nicht jeder Windows hat
Okay
Also wie geht das jetzt
Dieser Profil kopiert die Dateien auf ein existierende
Ja das ist okay
Excellent das will ich haben
Also sudo device dev zum iso
Home machen wir mal komplett
Windows 11 dev sdb
Okay er kopiert
Oder ist ja extrem high speed
Okay mit wenn toll probieren was das nächste Mal dann was macht der da für Dinger
Leute ich werde jetzt gleich den Snapshot restoren und das nie wieder anfassen den Stick
Lowercase Labels
Auch gut
Part 1 auf 241% ja das ist Microsoft die haben sich an den Microsoft progress Balken angepasst
Da geht das halt da wird halt so gezählt
Unter Windows
Wegen Fatsplit
Ja ich bin auch so fett mich müsste man auch mal splitten
Swimst du schon vom neuen Rechner nein ich mache ein Windows USB Stick für neuen Rechner
Eigentlich wollte ich das die letzte Stunde jetzt noch nutzen die Zeit schnell mal Windows installieren
Ach so Leute wisst ihr was mir da gerade einfällt
Windows 11
Ich ahne Schlemmes
Wir erklären ihnen in unserem breiteren Video wie sie Windows 11 auch ohne Microsoft
Okay also Windows 11 Pro mit einem offline Konto einrichten
Einfach kein LAN verbinden
Das war unter Windows 10 so ich weiß nicht ob das unter Windows 11 immer noch so ist
Ist das unter Windows 11 tatsächlich noch so
Geht immer noch ja dann werde ich die LAN Verbindung entfernen
Welche Linux Distribution ist dein Favorit
Arch Linux auf dem Desktop beziehungsweise auf dem VM so zum täglichen Arbeiten
Und Ubuntu beziehungsweise oder Debian letzter Zeit sogar eher Debian auf dem Server
Ich kenne mich ganz gut mit Red Hat auch aus weil wir das beruflich verwenden
Aber das hat eigentlich keine so wirkliche Zukunft finde ich so für die meisten
Weil entweder benutzt ein echtes Red Hat und bezahlt sich dumm und dämlich an Lizenzgebühren
Oder du benutzt CentOS was es in der Form nicht mehr gibt und mit 7 auch bald keinen Support mehr hat
CentOS 8 ist so ein Rolling Release Unstable Ding
Es gibt jetzt noch Rocky Linux und Alma Linux die sind aber so neu
Dass die keiner wirklich noch keiner schon richtig benutzen will
Da gibt es noch Suze die verwendet keiner der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist außer anscheinend Gonzo ist back
Und bleibt ja eigentlich nur Debian und Ubuntu noch
Oracle
Ja Oracle
Oracle benutzt du nur auf Datenbanken beziehungsweise auf Virtualisierungssachen von Oracle
Um Lizenzgebühren für Oracle zu sparen
Es geht nicht um Open Suze es geht um Suze Linux Enterprise Server
Aber es ist genauso schrecklich wie Open Suze
Ich habe schon wieder ganz verdrängt was mir daran nicht gefällt aber mir gefällt es nicht
So wie weiß ich noch
Es war PainsChamp
So haben wir es jetzt mit dem Kopieren
Hopp Hopp
Weil wenigstens die Winners Installation können wir noch durchklinken
Ich mache schon mal
Ich mache schon mal aus
Leute ich zeige euch mal was
Zack
Während er noch kopiert
Wir müssen uns gerade noch mal kurz was angucken
PostChamp
PostChamp schon mal für mich
Das Schwachsinn ist Aussage ihr müsst nicht PostChamp
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn zu PostChamp
PostChamp trotzdem mal
Achtung Achtung Leute
Decke aus
Licht aus
Huh
Nice
Sieht doch schon mal ganz cool aus
Lass aus
Ok Leute ich mache jetzt die volle
Die volle RGB Ladung
1000 Watt Netzteil
Ich mache jetzt die volle RGB Ladung
Ich mache am Fenster noch RGB an
Habt ihr gesehen wie ich am Fenster RGB
Guck ich mache am Fenster jetzt die RGB
Beleuchtung an
Ihr seht jetzt ein bisschen hier unten die Spiegelung
Wir haben jetzt den kompletten Raum RGBsiert
Komplett RGBsiert
Fenster
Rechner
Ram
Das allerwichtigste zu RGBsieren
Das Wort gibt es nicht wirklich aber irgendwie ist mir das gerade so
Ich finde RGBsieren hat was
Ver RGBsieren wir haben ver RGBsiert
Ja und hier unten am Mainboard da
Was man nicht gerade sieht da unten sind noch ein paar RGB LEDs
Die unsinnigste RGB Beleuchtung überhaupt ich glaube
Die haben die einfach da drauf gemacht dass sie sagen können
RGB Mainboard
Ansonsten gibt es da nichts
SSD RGB gibt es bestimmt schon
Es gibt ja auch Netzteil RGB
Aber ich habe mir kein RGB Netzteil gekauft bei ganz im Ernst
Wozu?
Wozu RGB Netzteil?
So der USB Stick ist immer noch nicht fertig
Das dauert 3 Stunden bis Grupp
Das hinbekommen hat
Leute am Wochenende
Kann ich euch schon sagen wisst ihr was wir uns morgen angucken zusammen
Nicht den neuen Rechner bauen
Es sei dann das Gehäuse ist da
Wir gucken uns morgen Nachmittag 15 Uhr
By the way 15 Uhr bin ich weg morgen
15 Uhr startet ein neuer DAWG FreeShot
Hier
Falls einer Bock hat eben DAWG
Wer Oldschool MMOs spielen will
Ihr wisst das ist mein erstes MMO was ich je gespielt habe
Und immer noch das geilste
DAWG wird noch gespielt naja auf dem FreeShot
Morgen startet ein neuer FreeShot
Um 15 Uhr
Und da wird Kreisel grinded
Bis Level 50 am Stück
Na wahrscheinlich schaffe ich das nicht
Alles in einer Sitzung braucht er eher
2-3 Tage vielleicht für
Morgen ab 15 Uhr
Aber wisst ihr was wir vorher machen
Ach übrigens ich habe gerade gar nicht gesehen
Das ich hier guck mal Eden DAWG
Also wer Bock hat
Kann ich das angucken
Wie gesagt nur für wirklich Hardcore Oldschool MMO Spieler
Für mich aber immer noch Hyper Graphics wie man da recht sieht
Aber bestes PVP MMO aller Zeiten
Morgen 15 Uhr startet der Server
Und ich werde da erstmal richtig durchgrinden
Und vor 15 Uhr
Wisst ihr was wir vor 15 Uhr machen morgen
Morgen gucken wir uns Terraform mit Google Cloud an
Warum mit Google Cloud
Weil ich bei Google Cloud nie was finde
Und ich beim Vorstellungsgespräch nächste Woche
Vielleicht Sachen zu Google Cloud gefragt werde
Und ich deswegen meine Google Cloud Kenntnis
Wieder mal ein bisschen auffrischen will
Ich habe schon einen Test Account gemacht
Mit 300 Dollar
Also wie gesagt Leute wer Bock auf DAWG hat
Ohne Scheiß
Bestes bestes MMO
Bestes PVP
Das aber nur für Leute die MMOs spielen wollen
Die wirklich Multiplayer sind
Wann geht's los 15 Uhr morgen
Also wirklich nur wenn ihr Multiplayer in MMO mögt
Weil dieses Spiel wird von Anfang bis Ende mit anderen Leuten gespielt
Es sei denn du bist Solo Schleicher und kriegst nix gebacken
Ok also USB Stick
Ich anmounte den mal von Hand lieber
Wobei man SYNC hinterher sollte reichen
Blub blub blub USB Stick
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
Chat ihr dürft raten
Meint ihr er bootet von USB Stick oder nicht
Warum ist dann Host OS eigentlich Windows
Videoschnitt
Games
Streaming
Alles was man mit Windows gut machen kann
Und Rest mache ich mit Linux
So
Achso ich müsste mal resetten
Hier resetten
Ich habe den Reset Button gepusht
Dein Tipp wird Booten aber nicht installieren
Naja mal gucken
Erstmal bräuchte ich wieder ein Bild
Ein Bild wäre schon extrem nice
Ich glaube mit Monitor dran ist er deutlich schneller als jetzt die Capture Karte das checkt
Alter haben wir es heute, booten please
Ne der muss ja ins BIOS
512 GB RAM
64 GB RAM
Was sind wir
Was jetzt
Kann man da parallel zum Stream mitmachen
Gibt es ein paar Dinge die ich mir im Vorfeld einrichten muss
Was meinst du wie parallel mitmachen zum Stream
Achso du willst mit rum basteln
Ray Dankeschön für den Sub
Du willst mit rum basteln
Ganz einfach du brauchst einen Google Account
Und musst dir dann die Trial starten
Die Google Cloud Trial
Da kriegst du 300 Dollar für 90 Tage
Es ist gebootet
Bootchamp
Language to install
Keyboard Input Method
Urdu
Please German
German
Oh Gott ist das scheiße zu bedienen
Leute mein Mausrad scrollt nicht richtig
Was ist das denn
Oh ne Leute ich muss die Tastatur anstöpseln
Das geht so gar nicht
Moment Tastatur abmachen und am anderen anstöpseln
Ach ich seh nix zu dunkel
RGB nicht hell genug Leute
Ok
Ok German
Ok perfekt
Ey das kannste ja mal komplett knicken
Ok next
Install now jetzt brauch ich die Maus
Was ist das
Hoffentlich ist das ein RGB Tastatur
Ja ist es tatsächlich ist es das
Nope wir haben keinen Product Key
Brauchen wir glücklicherweise nicht mehr
Windows 10 äh Windows 11 Pro
Bro
Bre
Wie man heutzutage sagt habe ich mir sagen lassen
Customize
Next
Ok die SSD erkennt er schon mal
Alt plus den unterstrichenden Buchstaben
Oh
16 Tipps die nicht mal Microsoft weiß
Nice
Hier lernt man was Chat
Bildungsauftrag wieder
Komplett erfüllt
Poggers
Extremely Poggers
Maus
Oh
Ich zieh mal kurz die Tastatur wieder ab
Und mach die an anderen Rechner
In der Hoffnung ich brauch ihn jetzt brauchst du da dran nicht mehr
Ok nice
Ihr könnt dazu gucken
Bei der Installation
Achso für Benutzernahme und so
Fuck stimmt
Da flutscht es
Also Wasserkühlung, irgendwelche Geräte
Und dann
Da
Also Wasserkühlung, irgendwelche Geräusche
Nichts zu hören
Das Case ist nice oder
Müsst ihr zugeben
Ein extrem nice Case
Bleibst du auf Windows 11
Ja wird mir nicht viel anderes übrig bleiben
Nur der Windows 11
Task Scheduler unterstützt die ganzen neuen
Cores sehr gescheit
Your computer will restart several times, this may take a while
Ja das sind wir schon gewöhnt
Ja da kann es Mashify oder so
Gehäuse einpacken also der Airflow hier
Ist wirklich legendär, wobei so geil
Ist der Airflow gar nicht
Weil die Airflow im ganzen Raum
Die streicht jetzt nicht unbedingt explizit
Gezielt da drüber
Ich mach mal kurz
Ich mach mal kurz Finger drauf
Nix
Das langweilt sich
Das Zeug
Wow
Okay
So heiß wie ich dachte
Ist es nicht
Hier ist übrigens die SSD drunter
Hier ist die SSD drunter, deswegen hab ich da mal gerade
Rauf
Gefingert
Windows needs to restart
Restart
Damit hätte keiner gerechnet
Hättet ihr damit wirklich gerechnet, ich dachte es läuft jetzt durch
Und dann kommt Cortana
Nee Cortana gibt's nicht mehr
Cortana ist auch so ein Ding
Wo Microsoft angefangen hat
Und sich dann gedacht hat Nope
Fast ein bisschen wie Windows Phone
Was soll das eigentlich darstellen
Ein Adler oder
Ein Adler mit der
Das ist ein Adler der Poggers
Guck mal das ist ein Adler der so den Mund offen hat
Ein Pock
Pock-Igel sozusagen
Oder Igel-Champ
Ist Cortana nicht tot doch
Ihr seht nix
Moment
Jetzt seht ihr was
Guck mal
Was ist das
Ist das ein Adler der Poggt
Igel-Champ
Igel-Igel
Angelhaken
Adler mit Faust
Also ne Faust erkenne ich da jetzt nicht
Flaschenöffner ja tatsächlich
Aber eh ist noch ein Flaschenöffner
Adler mit Pimmel
Chat da wäre ich jetzt nicht
Das ist so dumm man
Adler mit Widerhaken
Oh da sind wir Leute
Windows am Start
So dumm I can't
Was ist das ich bin blind
Ich bin blind
Auch jetzt kommt dieser Setup Shit
Is this the right country for your region
No
Oh ne falsche Maus
falsche Maus
Okay
Andorra
Alter mein Mausrad funktioniert nicht
Was ist denn das
Seriously
Geht es jetzt nicht anders oder wie
Geht es nicht anders
E F G
Gleich sollten wir kommen Germany
Excellent
Yes
Ich mag das mit Input lag Mäuse zu bedienen
Ehrlich gesagt nicht
Muss ich das wieder oh please
German
Ja please
Jetzt knackst das Mikro gerade ein bisschen
Was ich mir an das link
Skip please
Lass mich in Ruhe
Natürlich
Not connected
Ja ja ich weiß
Absicht
Nein nein nein wir connecten uns nicht
Wie geht das nicht mal weiter
You need an internet connection
To continue setup your device
Microsoft ihr Ficker
Ihr Wichser man
Ich hat euch
No
Warum habe ich Knacks in dem Mikrofon verlegt, ist das an der Capture Card oder so?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja okay, dann sind wir an der Stelle hier fertig würde ich sagen, hä?
Shift F10?
Oh, da muss ich die Tastatur anstecken.
Moment, was ist denn mit meinem?
Mein Headset knackst.
Liegt das an der Capture Card?
Sekunde.
Yep, liegt an der Capture Card.
Machen wir uns wieder rein.
One Moment, please.
Ich kann das Setup nicht weitermachen.
Wie willst du das Setup weitermachen?
Du kannst dir nichts anklicken.
Okay, geht auch ohne.
Wie denn?
Wie soll es ohne gehen?
Laden rein, Laden raus?
Okay, was?
Shift F10?
What the hell?
Alter, die dreckigen Figur von Microsoft, man.
Das fuckt mich jetzt mal so richtig ab.
Wie kann man so ein Rotz, man?
Ich will keinen Microsoft account, um mich da einzuloggen, man.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Sollen sie sich verpissen mit ihrem kack Microsoft account, man?
Obviously muss man das eintippen, ja.
Shift F10?
Okay, was?
Oh, oh, ich kann da nichts tippen.
Okay, OOBE slash bypass NRO.
Nein, Chat.
Ach, Backslash?
So?
What?
Alter, was ist das?
Was, was bin ich sehend hier?
Was mache ich hier überhaupt gerade?
Und jetzt?
Bootet er neu, geil.
Boah, da, da entwickle ich wirklich Aggressionen gegenüber Microsoft, wenn ich mir so, wenn
ich sowas sehe.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Country is right.
Nein.
Och man, Microsoft, warum kriegt ihr die einfachsten Sachen nicht hin, ihr dreckigen Kackpisser,
Alter?
Das regt mich so auf.
Und jetzt merkt ihr euch das, jetzt muss ich den Scheiß wieder auswählen.
Das ist ja fast schon so schlimm wie bei der Bahn.
Wie kann man so einen Scheiß nur entwickeln, Alter?
Skip.
Ei, doch, da ist es, da ist es.
Ja, ja, limited Setup, mein A, mein, mein S, äh, Test, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, das fliegt
dann eh wieder runter.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, oh Gott, kann man das nicht einfach skippen?
Kann man nicht einfach sagen, ich skippe, ich skippe die Questions, äh, nein.
Headname, Lul, next.
Name of City, Kekl, next.
Childhood Nickname, Omega Lul, ah, wenn man das Passwort nennt, Location, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, kommst du dir doch echt verarscht vor, oder?
Das sollst du noch Geld bezahlen für den Rods.
Kann man sich davon vorstellen.
So, darf ich jetzt mal nen Netzwerkabel reinstecken?
Nein?
Oh, oh, ok ich mach raus, ich mach raus Ich hab wieder rausgemacht
Schrecklich Ok, sagt mir mal, wie heißt denn der ganze
Krempel nochmal zum Temperaturnachkommen Also wir brauchen GPU-Z, nee CPU-Z brauchen
wir Wir brauchen Prime95 und uns Cinebench und so was
Und wir brauchen HW-Info Genau, da sind wir doch schon
Jetzt kann ich das Kabel reinstecken mit Internetstells
Ok Das lag, das ist jetzt ein bisschen laggy
Das Gigabyte Control Center Leute, kann es sein, dass ich das BIOS-Update
nochmal nicht richtig gemacht hab Ok, Reboot, Reboot, Reboote hier, ich hier
überhaupt richtig Ok, wie Rebooted man
Ok, da unten drauf, aber man kommt da nur mit der Maus drauf
Das ist alles maximal hängen geblieben gemacht Restart
Restart und ins BIOS, ich hoffe man muss entfernen drücken
Entfernen Shift, del, nee nee, del, will ins BIOS
BIOS has been reset, ok, alles klar Also, Advanced Mode
Ok Leute, was haben wir eingeschaltet, also XMP-Profile haben wir eingeschaltet
VTD haben wir eingeschaltet, richtig Weiß ich gar nicht wo das war
Wo ist denn VTD gewesen überhaupt Wo war das versteckt
Platform Power, Gigabyte, Gigabyte, config, utility, trash, weg
Wo war die CPU-Config, bei Tweaker Advanced CPU-Settings wahrscheinlich
VTD, nee Unter Favorites
Achja, ok das ist ansonsten irgendwo sonst wo versteckt
Ich hab halt übelstes Input-Lag, weil ich sie über die alte Capture-Card mach
VTD ist Intel-Virtualisierungskrempel Da kannst du zum Beispiel, also du kannst
auch virtualisieren ohne VTD, aber es ist sicherer und vor allem hast du ein bisschen
mehr Performance, sodass du im Endeffekt eigentlich keinen Unterschied merkst zwischen
CPU-Performance in der VM und CPU-Performance im Host, also wenn du ein Benchmark machst
in der VM und ein Benchmark machst auf dem Host ist quasi das gleiche, es ist das gleiche
es macht, also CPU-Performance ist in der VM eigentlich innerhalb der Messungenauigkeit
schon zwischen Host und VM Kann sich via RDP verbinden, das stimmt,
da müsste ich aber erstmal wissen wie man RDP einschaltet in Windows 11, ich glaube
bis ich das raus gekriegt hab, hab ich den anderen Crempel schon dreimal installiert
Gehst du auf VMWare oder VSL plus, VMWare, definitiv VMWare, ok da sind wir, würd mich
gerne einloggen Microsoft wenn das recht ist, Microsoft würd mich gerne einloggen,
hallo, ok, Display-Settings, mal den ganzen Kram ein bisschen hoch stellen, Alter warum
ist mein Scroll, Leute mein Scrollrad ist kaputt und ich hab halt übelsten Input-Lag
wegen der Capture-Card, Display-Resolution, warum kann ich meine Display-Resolution nicht
einstellen, Treiber, gibts da standardmäßig keine oder was, Film und Feature, kriegt man
die Sachen über Windows Update, Treiber und sowas, ne, oh Gott, Error Encountered, alter
man, funktioniert hier irgendwas, ja man gibt hier auch keine Internetverbindung, has no
Internet Access, Leute die Netzwerk-Card ist doch dran, oder hat die Netzwerk-Card nicht
erkannt, ich dreh durch, Alter, wo seh ich denn überhaupt meinen Netzwerk-Adapter die
Netzwerk-Adapter erkannt hat, unidentify-Network, oh ist doch gut alles, ey diesen Kram kann
man immer, also es ist ja dran, ich seh es ja am Switch, was, warum geht das, er erkennt
doch mein Netzwerk offensichtlich, man ich kann das nicht bewegen, ich kann das nicht
bewegen mit, mit Input-Lag über die Capture-Card, ja ist doch gut, Identifying, was will er
denn Identifying, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn man, was identifist du denn, was will er
denn Identify, man das ist so abgrund tiefer Bullshit dieses Betriebssystem man, was ein
Rotz wer diese Scheiße auch immer programmiert hat man, ich will ein Netzwerk-Kabel reinstecken
und dann soll mein Netzwerk funktionieren und ich kann sich gescheit bedienen über
Input-Lag von der Capture-Card, also ich kann ja immer großartig rumklicken, ich müsste
Pass-Through auf den Bildschirm machen, was, ok Firewall oder welche Settings, was soll
ich denn überhaupt gucken man, was ist das für eine Scheiße alter, es ist doch offensichtlich
ein Treiber drauf, sonst wird er das noch nicht erkennen, dass Link-Speed ist, er ist
irgendwie der Meinung, ALTER!
Ich brauche keine Netzwerk-Adapter Treiber, man sieht doch, dass die Netzwerk-Adapter
Karte erkannt ist und ich kann die Scheiße nicht bedienen, weil mein Mausrad nicht geht
unter Windows 11, mein Mausrad geht nicht Leute, das Mausrad geht nicht, das ist sowas
was natürlich, was habe ich netz gemacht, das Mausrad, stell euch mal vor das Mausrad
geht nicht, guck mal hier mein Mausrad, ach nee, ja guck mal hier mein Mausrad, seht
ihr das, ich scrolle die ganze Zeit die gleiche Richtung, nice, unidentified network, ok
was mache ich dagegen jetzt, warum ist das unidentified, ich raste aus, Scheiße, reset
all network adapters, perfekt, mach mal, ich habe doch gerade eben neu gestartet, das bringt
nix, was, jaja ok mach mal, reset, ok wisst ihr was, wir machen tatsächlich CMD, IP-Config,
ok, wir haben einen Netzwerk-Adapter, aber wir kriegen keine DACP-Adresse, warum, macht
keinen Sinn, Switch ist an, ich gucke mal kurz auf der anderen Seite, ob der Switch
angesteckt ist, aber ist er, das ist der gleiche Switch, wo es im Raspberry Pi war, ok Leute,
ich Reboot jetzt, ich Reboot jetzt, über den Knopf vom Mainboard, ich habe jetzt Reset-Button
gedrückt, schaut nach Generic-Driver aus, ist doch egal, ist doch vollkommen egal, das
erkennt, dass es Netzwerk-Karte ist, das muss funktionieren, ja Reboot, das ist Windows,
Reboot hilft immer, er kennt ja das wirklich, ja er sieht doch auch wenn ich das Kabel rein
und raus mache, das Netzwerk-Kabel, also er kennt das Netzwerk-Adapter am Start ist, wegen
der Uhrzeit, also wenn er mit der Uhrzeit Probleme hat, eine Netzwerkverbindung zu hin
bekommen, dann weiß ich auch nicht, hat er mit der Uhrzeit nichts zu tun, muss ja keiner
HTTPS SSL-Verbindung machen, HTTPS braucht Uhrzeit, ja ich weiß, aber wir machen keine
HTTPS-Verbindung, ich habe es gelesen, muss ich 5 mal schreiben mit der Windows-Fehlerbehebung,
so kannst du mal neu starten Rechner please, er hat sogar schon den Switch, aha, jetzt
blinkt der Switch auf einmal so, als hätte er sich eine DACP-Adresse geholt, jetzt muss
nur noch, jetzt muss nur noch der Kram starten, was jetzt, Windows, please, machen wir den
USB-Stick ab, booten, plitz, ok nice, so passt mal auf, immer noch keine Internetverbindung,
aber der blinkt, der Netzwerk, aha, alter dieses Abfahrt-Control-Center gehen wir nicht auf
den Sack man, ok wisst ihr was, ich will das nicht, ich will das nicht, das ist doch,
das ist doch Shit oder, ob denn, ok wir haben angeblich eine Internetverbindung, aha, yeah,
ich habe den Krempel doch ausgeschaltet in den BIOS, aber wahrscheinlich erst nach Installation,
ja, Reboot hat anscheinend geholfen, ok gut, also Edge, ich lade das jetzt unter Edge runter,
meinetwegen ist mir egal, ich kriege echt Anfälle, kann ich keinen Browser aufmachen
ohne einen Account?
Ich habe halt übelsten Input-Lag man, ok, also
ja ja, Massive Auflösung haben wir hier am Start, ich vergaß, mein Scrollrad funktioniert
ja nicht, hat Windows Update, kann Windows Update vielleicht die, was macht Windows Update
eigentlich, hat das jetzt, war Grafik-Treiber oder, was ist hier los, Display-Treiber, Leute
gleich haben wir Hi-Res Auflösung, ok also, was brauchen wir denn, wir brauchen, keine
Ahnung, Prime95, GIMP, korrekt, wir brauchen, wie heißt das Ding, HW-Info, AIDA64, ne wie
hieß der Krempel nochmal, was, das Zeug zum Anzeigen von den Temperaturen, HW-Info, ist
das das Richtige, ja CPU-Z brauchen wir jetzt erstmal, ist das das Richtige oder ist das
Fake, Alter was das, das ist, das doch nicht, kein Adblock, can't wait, Alter, sag mal,
das will ich doch nicht wirklich installieren hier oder, hey wir haben ordentliche Auflösung,
Pog, ok was, was lädt man runter, der Fosthub, portable, ja auf man, oh die Maus ist halt
mit übelstem Input-Lack, ok nice, gleich haben wir es, ich will einfach nur einen Benchmark
machen, Temperaturen sehen, mehr will ich gar nicht Leute, das letzte für heute, mehr
will ich nicht, 32bit, 60bit, egal wir entpacken einfach beide, so sieht Input-Lack-Maus aus,
oder, weil ich das hier über Capture-Card habe, ok nice, ahja, wir haben ja kein, kann
man alle tappen, so Prime95 und Cinebench, Cinebench, wie spricht man das überhaupt
richtig aus, habe ich mich nicht ausgesprochen, Cinebench 23 glaube ich das letzte, angeblich
hatte ich das schon offen, ich habe da so meine Zweifel, ob ich das schon offen hatte,
ist das der richtige Installer Leute, ich habe das ewig nicht mehr runtergeladen, ist
das das richtige, Maxron.net, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok.
Ok, Restart required. Neineineineinei уже ist nichts Restart required. Alter die Maus
mit Input-Lack, das ist so, ah fuck, ich brauch'n deswegen, ich kaufe mir auch eine neue Starting-Card
jetzt Ende des Jahres noch, das ich sowas ohne Input-Lack machen kann. Die Elgato ist
Super zum Captchern, aber so für Live-Input ist halt Müll.
Die Alte, die hat halt so ne Sekunde Verzögerung, da drehste halt echt durch bei.
Ich entpacke alles auf den Desktop.
Hoffentlich konflikten jetzt keine Dateien.
Es ist blöd da, ne da muss ich, ich hab ja ein Output an der Captchern-Card, aber da
müsste ich ein HDMI-Kabel an Monitor packen und sowas.
Erstmal Desktop voll machen, korrekt.
Ob ich jetzt RDP eingeschaltet hab, weiß nicht.
Ok wir haben alles was wir brauchen, nice.
Restart Now, ok das geben wir ihm jetzt mal, Restart Now.
Und dann machen wir die Benchmarks, guck mal wie warm das Ding wird.
RDP, ne würd mich wundern wenn das defaultmäßig an ist.
Kann ich nicht vorstellen, dass RDP defaultmäßig an ist.
Updates are under way, oh please keine halbe Stunden Update jetzt machen.
Wie warm ist denn die SSD?
Ah Geh das ist nicht wirklich warm.
Ganz ruhig Max.
Dieses OS Mann, es ist halt leider, so muss man halt leider so sehen.
Du hast halt in vielen Bereichen keine wirkliche Alternative.
Wo soll ich mein Zeug spielen?
Soll ich ordentlich Livestream machen mit dem passenden Gerätesupport?
Wo soll ich mein Vegas verwenden zum Videos schneiden?
Letztendlich ist es unterm Strich halt leider, trotz dem Abfuck von Windows, es immer noch
unterm Strich angenehmer Windows zu verwenden, das ist ja das Schlimme.
Obwohl das so unterirdisch schlecht ist das ganze, so schlecht Alter.
Haben wir es jetzt bald?
Ok aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist der Input abgekackt, ok, weiß.
Aber mal ein Reboot zwischendurch, kann man ja mal machen.
Mit JBoss, nee kenne ich mich nicht aus, mit Wildfly kenne ich mich auch nicht aus, ich
weiß, dass es Application Server sind für Java, das war es aber auch.
Ich weiß, dass die coolen Leute heute alles Spring Boot verwenden.
Ey da sind wir, das haben wir auch eine ordentliche Auflösung, ich stelle mir das mal vor.
So Benchmark Time, mal schnell, bevor wir ins Bett gehen.
Ja Windows, ok gut, ey wenn sich dieses Control Center nicht gleich verpisst da unten, dann
dreh ich am Rad.
Ok also, up, Run as Admin, bam, yes, start, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok.
Ach das genau, das meine ich, das meine ich, yep, yep, yep, yep cock, das meine ich hier.
Alter, die Maus man, das meine ich, ähm, gibt es da nicht so ein Summary oder sowas?
Ich meine, ich brauche das jetzt nicht für alle Cores, ja?
Ach nee, das ist nicht für alle Cores, das ist für eine CPU.
Ahja, ja, ok.
Also hier, das interessiert mich, das da interessiert mich.
Hier, Temperature, Temperature und Core Max und wo, wo ist, ähm, ah, da unten ist Power
Limit, alles klar.
Ok, Scene Binge, da wollen wir mal.
Ja, ja, wir accepten, muss ich wieder mal ausklinken.
Aim wie mein Opa, accept, Single Core, einmal Single Core please, nein, ich habe es nicht
zugemacht.
Habe ich AWInfo zugemacht?
Ich habe, ich habe AWInfo nicht zugemacht, ich habe AWInfo auf den Desktop geschickt,
äh, in den Background geschickt.
Wo ist es denn hin?
Im Tray?
Ahja, ok, hier, was haben wir denn da, wo, wo muss man da drauf gucken, da, ok, das Ding
bleibt, also Single Core bleibt das kühle as fuck, juckt den nicht, juckt den nicht,
juckt den nicht, schieben wir das mal so hier hin, mach mal Clock, mach mal Temperature,
ich habe doch hier unten oder?
Ach ne, du meinst hier die, die einzelnen Cores, mann ey, mit dieser Input lag Maus,
das ist wirklich eklig.
Das da, ne, das hört ja, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf, lull, P, E, Core, E, Core,
Core, was ist die vollen Limit, ich glaube Unlimited, ok, ok, dann, jaja, Stop, Stop,
stopp multicore bämm
alter bis ich das offen hab ist der test wieder vorbei
ist doch vollkommen ok
temperaturen sind noch vollkommen in ordnung
temperaturen sind richtig gut
guck mal hier da boostet alle core noch 5,5
kann sich überhaupt nicht beschweren die temperaturen sind noch absolut top
wo wo ist der wo ist der stromverbrauch
wo wo wo stand nochmal der stromverbrauch
irgendwo haben wir doch eben den stromverbrauch gesehen wo ist denn das
ich kann jetzt alleine nicht gescheit rumklicken
irgendwo steht doch hier stromverbrauch
es ist halt so abfuck mit dieser input lag maus
ist der test fertig oder macht doch im hintergrund noch zeug
ne rendering pass 5 macht er
tabelle breiter
wir hatten doch eben die die den verbrauch
ja 200 268 watt
270 watt ich hab hab ich nicht
komm mal power limit ist unlimited hier
nur die cpu nur die cpu
soll es den task manager aufmachen wie macht man unter windows jetzt den task manager auf
leute ich hab keinen plan mehr für hat man die rechts geklickt geht ja nicht mehr
wir sind jetzt der neue task manager wie macht man den auf hat ihr habt den plan
task mgr ja das geht auch
da haben sie sich ja so gefeiert vor auf ihrer auf ihrer konferenz beautiful new task manager
also ein rotzding was es im prinzip schon auf github tausendmal besser gibt so ok ist
ausgelastet wie konnte man den mist jetzt noch mal umstellen auf pro core so schon mal
nicht dass er alle course anzeigt
rechts klick
logical processors excellent oder ist gut ausgelastet würde ich sagen
aber ohne missleut die temperaturen sind doch absolut top kann sich ja wirklich nicht beschweren
hier 86 grad 85 86 grad ist doch richtig richtig top
ne ohne scheiß ich hab fest damit gerechnet dass der im multi core benchmark unlimited
power erstmal direkt an die 100 grad dran klatscht
dass das offen vor mir nicht ja aber trotzdem alter boost ist auch volle pulle 5,5 morgen
werden ein bisschen übertaktet noch würde ich sagen
vollkommen ok machen wir noch mal prime 95
aber AVX aus any primers chat für meinen stress haben wir noch ein paar primers unabhängig
davon ob ihr mir euren primes abgeben wollt oder nicht lasst ihn nicht verfallen das ist
das wichtige ob ihr mir gebt das mir egal ist mir wirklich egal aber gebt ihm irgendjemand
anstatt ihn verfallen zu lassen verfallen zu verfallen lassen primes ab ist richtig
bb gar ok ich brech mal ab brech mal ab dankeschön gonzo speck oh der suzzi linux user
ok prime leute machen wir AVX aus AVX ist doch total unrealistisch
leute es ist prime 95 meine fresse alter windows run anyway jan dankeschön doppel jan jan
r34 und jan jett just stress testing wir wollen gibs nicht join disable AVX
please small ffts test maximum power ane disable AVX muss man unten
ok seht ihr das wie viele wie viele dinger da einfach mal aufgehen
ich würde gerne das hier öffnen please öffnen mausleck
geht voll klar man die temperaturen sind weniger schlimmer als ich gedacht hätte
mal ab ach stimmt meinte prime dauert noch ein bisschen bis es hoch geht
stromverbrauch stromverbrauch ist progas
ein arctic cooling freezer 420 also das fetteste so ein all in one dinger was es aktuell so
gibt wo war die temperatur 640 also guck mal hier unten steht power limit es ist eigentlich
unlimited oder sehe ich doch richtig 4095 mehr geht nicht
die temperatur sind ok die wasserkühlung ist tatsächlich ordentlich am rauschen
also das muss man sagen das hört man jetzt deutlich wollt ihr wollt ihr auch mal hören
ich glaube das hört man nicht weil ich noise cancelling drin hab ich bin jetzt direkt neben
dem lüfter also das hört man ich hoffe ihr hört es auch
ich hoffe ihr hört es aber an sich vollkommen in ordnung alter
noise cancelling zu gut halbkorn dankeschön für den sub ja dann basteln wir morgen mal
ein bisschen würde ich sagen guck mal mal wieviel man da noch rausholen kann und wie
warm er denn dann wirklich wird als wobei morgen wollte ich eigentlich google cloud
gucken weil ich nachmittags mmo crying muss aber leute nachdem ich reddit gelesen habe
ja wo die leute rumgeheult haben bei dem ersten benchmark den sie aufgemacht haben wäre das
ding direkt an 100 grad ran geklatscht welches mmo daug freeshot eben daug eben
die temperaturen sind doch echt im grünen bereich ich mein früher hätte man gesagt
fuck alter manchmal 85 grad das wird aber ganz schön warm aber die dinger sind ja dafür
ausgelegt dass sie bis 100 grad easy laufen können was ich gezahlt habe 2200 euro ungefähr
was bin ich was bin ich da unten sehend morgen gucken wir auch mal ob da power limit drin
ist und sowas aber sollte eigentlich kein power limit drin sein was bringt der da etwas
ich habe keine ahnung ob er was bringt ich habe es nicht mit und ohne getestet aber mit
den temperaturen bin ich mehr als zufrieden guck mal das ding ist unter volllast okay
zum schluss eine sache jetzt bringen wir mal an die 100 grad jetzt jetzt bringen wir mal
die 100 grad seck leute 100 grad incoming 100 grad incoming das letzte was wir heute
machen leute wo starten wenn ihr noch mal einen test hier test test nee wo war dieses test
window noch mal ich habe den mausleck ihr müsst mir mal helfen kurz tests bürker windows
nee oder ich habe den alten test doch beendet
ich will einfach einen neuen test starten options wahrscheinlich torture test chat ich
sag's mal wieder ihr habt genauso wenig ahnung wie ich small ffts und jetzt mit a4x und jetzt
mit und jetzt mit a4x jetzt sind wir 100 pro jetzt immer gleich bei 100 grad
test da drossel der direkt und und da ist er hat schon nicht mehr auf 5500 500 geboostet
sondern boost nur noch auf nur noch auf 5000 ja ok ok a4x ist ist ist rib zeigt power consumption
wo ist das 324 watt jetzt ist auch bei 100 grad leuten jetzt ist vorbei jetzt ist vorbei
aber das ist halt komplett das ist halt komplett realitätsfern alter keck
ok wir machen jetzt 17 explore ich will ich will es noch mal ohne starten desktop mit input
leck maus ist wirklich ganz ganz furchtbar leute glaubt's mir
maximum heat disable
ist ohne scheiß die temperaturen sind wirklich nicht verkehrt das ist echt ok guck mal ich
mein der ist unter volllast unter volllast hat er 90 graden wenn es hochkommt ne 64
thread threads bringen ja nix also maximum unter volllast kriegen wir 700 270 watt nur
die cpu nur die cpu da kommt jetzt ja noch die grafikkarte dabei das sieht schon ein
bisschen was ok leute letzter blick ich mach mal die tastatur schon weg was war das jetzt
ach das war über den elgato sound wenn tastatur kurz rüber wieder
ein letzter blick leute nur heute
da ist er ist er nicht ne nice kiste wir haben 86 grad unter kompletter volllast also ohne
scheiß jetzt mal ernsthaft ich dachte der wird wärmer ich dachte der wird wärmer weil
alle weil alle rumheulen du kriegst mit keiner kühlung diese cpu gekühlt das case ist gut
ja noch ist er in keiner kiste ja aber trotzdem
die leute berichten auf reddit teilweise dass du instant am 100 grad limit bist sobald du
den benchmark anmachst ne so krass war das beim 8700k nicht also ich scheine eine ganz
gute cpu erwischt zu haben und vielleicht hat auch der kontakt frame was gebracht alles
möglich aber wenn das so bleibt also ich könnte ich könnte nicht glücklicher über
die temperaturen sein 98 grad 8900 grad mit avx was total unrealistisch ist realistisch
betrachtet volle pulle 100 prozent cpu last ohne avx maximum 87 grad ja leute im sommer
im sommer ist es hier drinnen vielleicht paar grad wärmer aber auch keine 35 grad selbst
dann macht sie die temperatur differenz aus und das bissl ist es nicht ist kein kein ding
ja also ist wirklich wirklich sehr sehr nice gefällt mir gut ja morgen machen wir das
nie war morgen habe ich keine zeit ja wir machen auch das intel tuning tool mal drauf
machen und gucken ob man nicht noch irgendwie all core turbo einschalten oder sowas ok mal
kurz den finger das ding wird schon recht warm ja spannungswandler und so ssd also das
ganze system wird hat weist eine gewisse wärme auf sage ich mal ja also das ist hat schon
ein bissl was passende outro musik ja das system ist übrigens immer noch unter voll
aus jetzt wenn ich gerade schon abstöpsel abstöpsel gemp ok also ihr seht das ding
ist ordentlich am flutschen dahinten flutscht flutscht gemp aber schön kühl hier mal kurz
an der anderen seite fühlen da müsste die warme luft reinkommen ja an der seite bisschen
ein bisschen wobei oben wahrscheinlich oder oder unten unten unten ist wärmer ok aber
ich höre auch nichts kluckern oder so wirklich in ordnung ja und die dinger hier bleiben
dann auch ein bisschen kühler wenn im gehäuse ein bisschen luft bisschen luftfluss drüber
ist ssd temperaturen kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken ich habe schon hab schon abgestöpselt alles
ja alles ein bisschen wärmer aber sieht doch schick aus wir gucken uns dann auch demnächst
noch die rgb steuerung und sowas alles an also aktuell braucht er 280 watt nur nur voll
aus cpu und nur was wir sehen ich mache ich mache morgen dann mal so einen so einen strom
mess ding dran und wir gucken mal was er wirklich braucht weil er kommt in die wasserkühlung
noch dazu der verbrauch das bord und alles ja ok leute ich schalte jetzt einfach aus
pass mal auf ich bin jetzt ganz brutal wobei das machen wir machen wir nicht wenn man drücken
mal reset wir lassen die wasserkühlung noch ein bisschen nachlaufen hier ok das gehäuse
kommt wenn wir nicht glück haben morgen ja korrekt aber leute bettke time ich muss jetzt
schlafen ich bin bin schon hab schon massig überzogen wie viele watte hat das netzteil
3000 wir sehen uns dann macht's gut bis morgen zu